salut stuff salut à tous yes bienvenue
Bienvenue dans ce speech donc le 8e de
finale attends j'ai pas mis les bonnes
caméras d'ailleurs ça commence bien
ça va le faire et
je suis encore désolé de vous avoir
quitté précipitamment stouf hier je
voulais savoir ça c'est bien fini parce
que je connais pas je connais pas le
résultat du tout
je connais pas le résultat d'hier
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans dans ce
dans ce duel
à te faire écoute tu avais parié sur
farine et ben écoute je pense que tu as
bien passé mon poulain
hier au départage Kiri gagne le premier
match des départages le deuxième qui
était complètement gagnant pour guéri
qui blender complet et finit par faire
nul la troisième partie encore une fois
qui peut tenir la nulle et qui perd et
la quatrième alors là c'était la faute
de souris de guéri qui perd la partie
enfin qui perd une pièce dessus et qui
grind qui grind qui Grinch qui remonte
et au final qui qui a dû faire nul et
malheureusement il était en mustwin il a
raté une fourchette à un moment donné il
a pas gagné la fille avec un pion de
plus voilà qui était nul de base mais
juste ça c'est incroyable d'ailleurs
d'arriver dans cette finale là alors que
tu avais juste une pièce de moins à
cause du de la faute de souris mais en
tout cas gros gros match hier en tout
cas je regrette d'avoir raté ça hein
franchement tu m'as fait un petit résumé
d'ailleurs qui était super merci à toi
du résultat
bon en tout cas aujourd'hui nouvelle
affiche et ben ça commence direct et
vous montrer déjà les appartements le
premier truc donc on a so Wesley avec
les Blancs donc so Wesley qui est
est-il mal mal réglé les gars et j'ai un
petit problème
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé qu'on est
chez qui alors ça les gars je ne peux
pas vous dire
ce qu'il s'est passé c'est pas grave si
on ignore la colonne A honnêtement on
est quand même pas mal stouf non mais
c'est très bizarre ce qui s'est passé là
parce que toi je vais à la place du
temps j'ai des trucs bizarres les gars
j'ai mon truc qui a tout déréglé
complètement
et je crois que je vais savoir pourquoi
voyables d'où ça t'auras franchement
hyper concentré c'est assez rigolo tout
mouvement parlait tout à l'heure en fait
on se rend pas trop compte mais ouais
c'est les sauts ils jouent sur une
chaise alors oui il est assis sur une
chaise effectivement et il a mis aussi
l'ordinateur portable sur une chaise en
face de lui du coup il est tout baissé
vous voyez enfin c'est c'est vraiment
pas une posture très académique on a
l'impression qu'il est juste parti pour
jouer quelques blistes non non il va il
va jouer pendant 4 heures le gars
incroyable quoi non c'est ouf alors moi
j'ai vu j'ai deux caméras et on voit
encore une fois
l'installation de so Wesley dans ce
match il est assis sur une chaise en
bois et il a posé son ordinateur sur une
chaise de bureau et comme ça accroupi et
moi j'ai vu ça j'ai dit mais c'est pas
possible quoi comment tu peux jouer
comme ça un match de 4h contre en plus
un joueur qui va qui vraiment juste
monstrueux et en face tu as off qui a
une table en marbre hyper grande table
l'ordinateur la souris la caméra juste
vraiment
le professionnel quoi deux styles voilà
et en plus chez So on a l'impression
qu'il y a pas de chauffage il est en
doudoune alors c'est vraiment très
spécial chez lui
sachez que stouf a parié parce qu'il
avait la primeur du Paris il a choisi
Wesley sceaux du coup je me retrouve
assez satisfait avec Abdou sa torov
parce que dans les cadences rapides et
quand même excellent aussi
même si on peut dire peut-être que saut
est légèrement favori je sais même pas
c'est tout fois honnêtement je sais pas
ce que tu en penses
oui bah je pense que saut est un favori
un sauce c'est un des joueurs qui
taquine quand même vachement le quand je
dis le niveau c'est c'est un scène et
Nakamura dans ce type de format qui
peuvent clairement les battre donc
généralement saut ne savent pas trop de
contreperts contre des joueurs un peu
moins fort que lui pour moi c'est un des
meilleurs vœux du circuit
et donc je le vois pas faire ce match
pour ça que j'ai parlé sur lui
aujourd'hui
mais quand même abuse
c'est c'est un jeune qui progresse
énormément qui vient de passer 1700 et
l'eau qui est à Champion du monde en
titre de de partir rapide donc c'est pas
du tout et donc le match promet d'être
vraiment très très intéressant mais je
pense enfin je pense quand même que ça
doit être favori quand même dans ce dans
ce niveau du style vestimentaire j'avais
choisi aussi la petite capuche fourrière
fourrure qui avait t'en fait parler hier
et du coup ça aurait été plus logique
que le choix dans l'équipe de West les
sceaux mais j'avoue que je suis pas
mécontent d'être pour pour Abdou sa
torov on sait à quel point il est il est
dangereux donc on va voir ça maintenant
et on est dans une italienne typique
j'ai un petit peu du mal moi perso de
avec les positions blanches de ce type
là quand le caveton F4 ça fait toujours
un petit peu peur tu vois il est
toujours disponible
en pratique à regarder ouais il y a eu
un match d'ailleurs en speed chest
c'était nvl contre dubaf et à chaque
partie de bof arrivé à avoir un truc
comme ça en train de VL et il avait eu
du mal une chance match la problématique
noire maintenant c'est comment on peut
améliorer parce qu'on manque quand même
d'espace et du coup tu me diras avec les
Blancs c'est un petit peu la même chose
c'est chaque coup ici avec chacun semble
difficile à jouer
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer justement
avec les Blancs à cavalier F5 à un
moment
si je souffle les bons coups à ton
poulain ça va pas aller quoi faut
vraiment comme ça moi je vais je vais
demander à saut de d'arrêter de te
copier parce que si tu veux gagner le
match
[Rires]
je pense que sur un match contre
même
ou pas
compris parce que comme je peux revenir
en G5
et toi
assez intéressant au final bien sûr tu
as tout à fait raison souffre
à Alex à Bratt et à Fatou
bienvenue à vous j'espère que vous allez
bien
est-ce que moi je peux lui donner une
épée à tout je pense pas
en tant que modo qu'est-ce qui se passe
cavalier F4
cavalier des 5
si il prendra
le pion H3 on a la première partie il y
a un sacrifice dans les dans les c'est
assez rigolo
[Musique]
alors le match secticao Arnaud bonjour à
toi il est à
19h en fait ce match là ici normalement
vers 19h et on enchaîne directement avec
ma caméra quand on part à ravial salut
Manil
salut salut à tous et Arnaud il voulait
savoir c'était quand ton match avec qui
il faut que me donne ce dispo
donc là il y a eu Kamal 6 prises là ok
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait
le roi de
mon petit Abdou ça Torah
il fait un départ modeste avec des
pièces noires
va me venger de guérir il est pas trop
Poker Face d'ailleurs Abdou ça torrent
on a vu que c'était euh max il est
expressif et enfin c'est si je pouvais
vous montrer
l'installation de ça franchement la gars
vous seriez mort de rire malheureusement
bon c'est c'est chez lui je peux pas
vous montrer tout ça mais c'est très
très drôle c'est très très drôle et
juste sur une chaise
comment il mange déjà juste taper une
table à la maison vous voyez je vais
vous dire comment comment il joue il est
assis les fesses posées sur une chaise
en bois et
l'ordinateur portable qui est posé sur
sur la chaise de bureau
et
d'où celle du plongeante sur
l'ordinateur
il est accroupi et c'est juste
hallucinant quoi et mais la végétarien
alors lors d'un match je sais plus je
pense pas qu'il soit opadre parce que là
il a qu'une seule main sur la tête vous
voyez je crois qu'elle a une souris mais
là mais il a il a pas beaucoup de marge
pour pour pouvoir bouger la souris vu
qu'elle soit une chaise donc le Bullet
j'ai un peu peur mais moi on verra en
tout cas j'ai quand même pétillant lui
là où j'ai bête sur lui avant de voir
son installation mais bon c'est pas
grave ouais c'est un des joueurs
fantasques du circuit donc lui peut se
permettre de faire ça personne ne peut
mais lui sans doute que c'est pas un
souci et là il est en train de ramener
toutes ces pièces à la fête sur roi
d'abusa fait du coup on sait que
[Musique]
ce type de position avec deux minutes
contre 20 secondes c'est quasiment déjà
plié
il a perdu en une vingtaine de coups
elle est très très rigolote cette
Italienne
[Musique]
des écrans tactiles tu as déjà vu moi
j'ai jamais vu les écrans tactiles
j'ai déjà vu au speech non jamais vu
mais en fait le tactile je l'ai essayé
enfin j'en ai mis qu'il y en avait un du
coup un jour j'ai essayé et toi tu
penses que ça va plus vite mais en fait
non tu vas pas bien le temps que tu as
et puis en fait tu es plus tu es
beaucoup plus lent avec le tactique
qu'avec une souris en fait moi seulement
rien à voir moi
qui parle de la vitesse de la fin tu as
mal au bras quoi
tu fais 4 heures avec ton bras à la fin
juste
adapté
il y aura pas encore mais ça va arriver
la tactique en s'inquiète pas trop une
plus une surprise comme il a pris 10 €
contre Magnus aïe a ok
maintenant en tout cas en 5 plus une il
a été bien chaud et il a bien écrasé le
petit abdos
allez faut se refaire tout de suite là
yes on démarre pas comme NiAl s'il vous
plaît hier ça fait peur quand même ouais
non ok mais là c'est quand même parti
quand même très convaincante cette
fois-ci de de saut et
vraiment c'était vraiment très bien et
j'ai pas compris sauf malheureusement on
n'a pas eu le temps de revenir dessus il
y avait quand même un événement assez
intéressant tu sais quand il a sacrifié
la pièce c'est que
il y a Abdou qui a répondu par un contre
pseudo sacrifice et à ce moment-là on a
on savait pas trop si on pouvait prendre
c'est intéressant ce moment-là il aurait
mérité de d'investiguer un peu plus loin
d'ailleurs Abdou qui est plus de 2700
bah il a il a dit non je n'y vais pas
donc c'est que voilà ça fait peur quoi
donc mettez la pression sur vos
adversaires quand vous jouez des parties
rapides et Blitz et même des parties
lentes tu es la clé de vos victoires et
les vous pouvez comme ça vraiment des
joueurs forts
ne laissez pas votre adversaire dans sa
zone de confort voilà ce que ceux nous a
appris ils sont par contre il joue une
vitesse aussi
il a fait vraiment une étude de savoir
comment est-ce que il a le plus efficace
en position aérodynamique bon j'aime
bien alors
Abdou avec sa proposition de joie un
jour pour tourger un etc il va être
obligé de ramener le cavalier en E3
parce que j'ai 4 en l'air
un roi change G4
mais finalement ça donne des cases aussi
on voit quand même que le cavalier noir
pourra un jour peut-être venir
une belle tasse d'ailleurs
[Musique]
un jour comme on pourrait essayer de se
projeter 5 c'est pas totalement
[Musique]
mais on voit que
tu lui as dit à son que c'était pas du
Bullet parce que là il joue avec
handicap autant quoi
ça c'est bien au niveau du moral
mais
bon c'est choquant
ça fait mal c'est sûr après est-ce que
est-ce que cartel joue pareil vous savez
quand vous jouez comme ça pour rigoler
et quand vous jouez avec une pression
d'un tournoi on joue quand même pas
pareil
j'ai l'impression qu'il arrive à faire
un peu abstraction du contact
que tu adores
punaise il a quand même pris cher contre
lui hein c'est le plus gros score du
speechestre on va voir dans quelle forme
d'ailleurs et ikara una kamura ce soir
ça peut être aussi un score fleuve
puisqu'on sait qu'il joue le ouais le
dernier hello de ce speechestre un Pavia
donc ça peut être un gros gros score
alors moi je suis prête à Paris
que le score de de carreaux contre
paravent va être plus élevé que le score
je pense que ça va être ça c'est déjà
c'est déjà énorme je pense qu'on va on
va faire un petit jeu d'enchères parce
que moi je pense qu'il va faire aussi
moins que ça
et il va falloir qu'on voit à quel point
on est prêt à aller mais
[Musique]
en fait je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on
fasse un petit jeu d'enchères à partir
de 1 ou 2 et qu'on monte petit à petit
tout tu vois parce que moi j'ai un
résultat qui meurt pas trop mal pour ma
tête parce que tu en penses moi je pense
à 4
c'est pas mal mais je dirais quand même
moi
c'est pour ça que entre 3 et 4
on a prévu un autre truc déjà on le fera
je pense aussi pour les pour chaque
manche mais on se fera un petit jeu
d'enchères tu vois on fera un petit peu
différent parce honnêtement on s'est dit
avec stouf qu'on pouvait ni l'un ni
l'autre prendre
bon voilà on va pas prendre par avia
entre guillemets alors qu'on sait que à
part une connexion Internet qui qui
déconnerait il y a toujours cette cote
là
et même pour un joueur comme mikaro il
pourrait trouver une règle ou il y
aurait suspension du match donc non on
va pas on va faire ça
c'est que à chaque à chaque 7 on peut
parier sur le
résultat de de parabian avec enchères et
aussi sur le résultat de fin du match en
fait et puis exactement
on sait quand même que là pour le coup
les bookmakers donnent Nakamura
gagnant avec
98,5 % article ça au 99% je sais plus
bon du coup celui qui prend pas c'est
pas très équilibré quand même clair ou
alors la grosse côte quoi
[Musique]
mais bon ok ça fait beaucoup quand même
donc du coup du coup dans on va rester
sur ça par contre là celui-là dans un là
c'est un match quand même assez normal
ce serait même possible de faire des
Pretty
on pourrait faire des prédits pour une
chaîne effectivement on pourrait en
faire je peux les faire après si vous
voulez
est-ce que Fatou est dans le chat les
gars
question pour Fatou
Fatou c'est notre modo chef
surtout toutes les toutes les chaînes
elle est modo de partout et j'ai une
question pour la meilleure d'entre nous
mais elle a pas l'air d'être là
partie prendre une pause on va jouer
savoir si si moi en tant que modo est-ce
que je peux donner le nom je pense pas
qu'en tant que modo je puisse la donner
la matmodo j'y crois pas mais peut-être
entre Nathan
j'ai un problème entre la colonne B les
pions sur casse blanche à surveiller on
voit qu'il y a toujours une minute
autant pour l'instant ouais c'est ça
fait une très très grosse impression il
laisse rien son jeune adversaire et le
travail même
voyez elle a rentré sur la colonne B à
quoi ça sert d'avoir une colonne bah
rentrer ses pièces dans le camp et demi
et faire mal donc
là c'est logique il sentait très mal
donc il essaie de compliquer de
chambouler la position sauf que pour se
faire il vient d'ouvrir toutes les cases
blanches alors qu'il n'a pas de foot
carrelage blanche puisque le fou qui a
aussi c'est actuellement pour les noirs
on va pouvoir se poster en D5 et faire
mal pendant toute la partie donc à la
fois c'est bien de cette chambouler mais
il a rien obtenu et puis ce qui est
surtout impressionnant c'est quand il y
a il y a cette offre qui prend des
réflexions de 10 20 secondes 10 20
secondes et ouais c'est les sauts il
prend toutes ses décisions en moins de
10 secondes depuis le début de cette
partie ouais c'est soit le maximum qu'il
est réfléchi ouais c'est sur un ou deux
coups là où il a pris un peu de temps
mais sinon c'est c'est voilà 10 secondes
max en moyenne
donc c'est très fort
là faudrait réussir à passer aussi
effectivement
dans de bonnes conditions
et les pièces les tours blanches suivent
derrière on y croit pas trop
surtout il y a 19 secondes quoi 19
secondes contre une minute 20 dans une
position extrêmement compliquée où le
roi blanc peut être à tout moment
en difficulté voilà il y a pas
osé jouer aussi parce qu'il s'est dit
qu'il allait perdre papillon et là voilà
le problème c'est le pion H3 et le foot
la Blanche a été donné
c'est déjà quasiment terminado
il est pas chaud chaud là boussator
et qui est plein de ressources et qui
jouent en fait qui est juste très très
bien quoi et pour vraiment Bado il fait
vraiment à mieux jouer avec lui quoi
parce que
c'est pas le joueur qui va qui va passer
une minute à sur un coup tu vois c'est
un jeu
qui joue plus vite
et pour l'instant ça va pas suffire là
clairement on a des gros problèmes avec
les Blancs on vient de faire tout RAV4
puis tout recadre revient parce qu'on
est on est sous pression on a un pion de
moi on a un roi faible
pour tout réflexion
de bricoler un truc mais
un modo qui a sa petite épée
Nathan qui qui est par là et d'ailleurs
j'ai demandé aussi attends que qu'il te
mette modo aussi Kévin
punaise là c'est vraiment encore texte
un problème tu imagines s'il pourrait
un séisme pour que je modère quelque
chose
je pense que le temps de réaction ou la
Tour Eiffel c'était modeste
le coup de fin bon ben 2-0 j'espère
qu'on va pas s'ennuyer dans son dans ce
match
ça peut que ça peut cartonner hein
j'ai pu choisir aujourd'hui en premier
Robinson et j'ai choisi so donc écoute
et ben je suis pas malheureux dans ce
début de match c'est terrible dans ces
matchs je dois choisir mon partenaire de
de club soit je subis la loi de stouffe
la loi des choix de stouffe et ça peut
faire mal
mais bon hier j'ai quand même parce que
hier franchement au niveau de
je pense de la chance franchement j'ai
pris sacrément cher faut bien que le
vent tourne un petit peu hier c'était
ouf
qu'il y avait quand même beaucoup de
réussite de ma part aussi mais là
c'était fou hier c'est en fait à chaque
7 là c'était c'était plus grossir mais à
chaque fois il y avait il y avait on
joue on joue de 7 sur une partie et à
chaque fois il se fait arnaquer sur une
partie et j'ai perdu deux sets en
faisant arnaquer et le et alors là le
partage final je parlais mais en fait
c'est important c'est l'impression que
je me suis voler absolument toutes les
tout le match quand même mais bon sympa
sympa en tout cas ça lui résonne
donc c'est c'est vraiment pas un tocard
c'est un max
c'est le mec qui est hyper régulier qui
va qui va pas blender en un coup quoi
c'est vraiment un joueur qui
j'avoue j'avais pas vu la belle tasse
qu'il a il a une belle tasse
il a une tasse du pays clairement j'ai
vu chez lui j'ai vu son intérieur voilà
de la pièce dans laquelle il est
franchement c'est hyper beau c'est hyper
bien et il a des conditions vraiment
assez incroyables alors que ce soit
[Musique]
avec l'ordinateur posé sur la chaise de
bureau c'est juste complètement
hallucinant et
mais bon ok
on a les mêmes pièces aux échecs donc on
peut faire un petit peu comme on a envie
salut Marius château pour jouer pendant
4 heures salut Marius
donc voilà pour toi
salut à toi en tout cas merci
du Roazhon
parking
c'est vrai qu'il faut être connaisseur
là
maintenant faut pas oublier ça sauf
deux j'aime beaucoup ce coup avec je
pense l'idée fougères
chasser avec un petit roi et du coup
même peut-être même mettre le four en F5
et ramener le cavalier en G3 la dame en
G4 tu vois et faire plus agréable pour
le moment pour
les blancs
[Musique]
H2 et G3 alors pourquoi
on peut jouer G3 cavalier prend H3 et
Roig G2 peut-être
ok donc j'ai trois cavalaires je crois
roi G2 on va voir
c'est compliqué un petit peu
je crois pas trop mais bon
en tout cas c'est marrant et consolide
vous avez vu il prend le centre et après
consolide et les Noirs ils sont obligés
un petit peu de
de se compromettre ils ont fait AG5 tu
as vraiment l'impression que les Noirs
ils sont bien alors cavaliers F4 tout ça
mais au final en fait il y a rien de
concret sur le roi blanc et du coup
positionnellement les blancs arrivent
toujours à à se replacer et en fait
après l'avantage avec les toiles les
autres
ils font quoi
[Musique]
même ouverture italienne que que tout à
l'heure dans la première partie et un
petit peu le même scénar on a du mal à
voir maintenant que vont entreprendre
les noirs
avec les Blancs on a des facilités
d'amélioration est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
jouer
un petit dame F3 quelque chose comme ça
bon c'est dames des deux qui a été
préférée dans F3 tout courra D1 ça avait
l'air d'être la logique aussi de la
position
je sais pas quel était l'idée du coup de
dame j'ai 6 petite pression sur le
centre bon ça fait pas mal
puis un jour des cinq peut-être pour les
Noirs aussi à surveiller
salut poulet Belgique
[Musique]
non il est complet en fait il est
complet il joue très bien toutes les
phases de jeu T5 pour une fois le fois
cette peu revivre donc ça va sans doute
s'échanger un moment bien sûr les Noirs
échangent attention à f-3 qui pourrait
déloger le cavalier c'est une
possibilité aussi on va voir comment ça
va se passer il y a aussi toujours la
pression sur E4 mais maintenant il y a
des découvertes à surveiller voilà c'est
pris en A7
B6
mais maintenant du coup peut-être B3
attention à bien jouer
et du coup la structure reste figée je
peux plus GB4 à cause de la prise en
passant et le pion à 3 serait faible en
fait à trois ça serait un très très
mauvais coup à une grosse faute grosse
stratégie non en plus on peut dire aussi
quand vous avez l'avantage d'espace au
centre il faut pousser à côté du sommet
de votre chaîne de pion donc en fait la
poussée clé c'est C4 C5 c'est pour ça
que tout va nous faire du A3 B4 et qui
commence par B3 pour pas se faire fixer
son pion B2 voilà
redonner ça dans les positions
B3 d'abord et ensuite on joue à 3 B4 et
C5 et comme le sommet chez les Noirs
c'est E5 bah il faudrait jouer à base de
F5 et il est en train de préparer ça
sauf que là il se fait attaquer il se
fait attaquer le pion G4 et que c'est
pas facile de trouver une solution et en
plus après la clonage c'est bien je peux
l'utiliser pour justement attaquer du
coup le roi noir
donc là j'ai quand même
bah j'ai mon problème avec l'option G4
stouf j'ai pas envie de pleurer mais
quasiment là ce que je dois jouer F5
pour rester de créer du jeu
en plus quand même donc quand je prends
G4 juste je récupère le pion mais je la
récupère avec des compenses qui est la
colonnage par exemple
l'incendie enfin il y a pas d'incendie
de toute façon enfin il y a pas de
contre jeu possible pour les noirs et
voyez il y a d'où ça te rave qui
s'inquiète de ce qui va se passer à
l'eldame parce que sur l'ensemble de
l'Égypte et les bloquer autrement
maintenant
B4 vous voyez parce que du coup si il
prend pas 100 je prends ici et tout va
bien
mais B4 prise est peut-être tour à 8 qui
gagnait la colonne
qui est B5
l'idée c'est qu'il veut faire prise et
tourbé 8 et essayer de créer du jeu sur
la colonne B très bien joué comme un
dans l'esprit
non c'est clair si il fait rien c'est
complet
très très vite depuis le début depuis le
début des parties il joue vite simple et
efficace franchement c'est l'horreur
pour l'instant
j'avais eu l'occasion d'ailleurs de
jouer Wesley saut dans un des seules
Tuesday que j'ai fait et franchement
pareil j'avais pas fait une mauvaise
partie mais je mettrai pris une bonne
déjà le la vitesse tout enfin c'est
juste l'horreur parce qu'on se rend pas
compte qu'on est sur l'échiquier mais je
pense qu'à Abdou il a joué assez vite
cette partie et malgré tout il est quand
même moins bien autant légèrement cette
fois mais c'est pas facile
là il commence à manquer de coup
je suis un petit peu inquiet tu veux
jouer quoi juste eu et prise
c'est toujours difficile
il y aura une rentrée en B2
pas simple du tout
appuie
qui commence un petit peu à bloquer
niveau du temps là il fallait qu'il le
joue je pense avant à tempo parce que
[Musique]
c'est très très
chaudes donc je peux pas trop
[Musique]
et maintenant il y a la colonne h
ouverte donc il y a des axes quand même
sur le roi donc il y a tout à huit
damascal
heureusement on a aussi du contre jeu
quand même à Glais noir sur le pion F2
sur le pion E4
aussi il faut regarder un tour à 8 et
des coins intermédiaires ouais
un dame C8 magnifique mais il y aura
toujours d'un E4 pour pour sortir
ok bon là il y a des chances chances
d'égalité forte maintenant
tu vas juste manger là manger là
pourquoi il a mis du temps à jouer dans
ma chiche un peu étonné mais peut-être
qu'ils vont faire nul ici c'est pas
possible
je pense qu'il y a il a aucune chance de
[Musique]
avec le pion passé je pense qu'il avait
pas de risque il a un peu de pu essayer
de la jouer quand même
tu as raison c'est un petit peu plus
facile bon et le fait qu'il mène de zéro
a dû l'influence quand même
ouais mais bon
jusqu'à présent il a super bien géré son
temps il s'est retrouvé avec 5 secondes
bon
ouais
salut à toi il est en difficulté à 12
ans quand tu joues avec avec deux
options tu vois genre
c'est toujours enfin si la personne joue
bien bah c'est mieux le toi il faut
essayer de la joker
non je suis d'accord avec toi on a vu
NiAl hier on a vu hier il avait pas
besoin d'être bien pour tenter ce genre
de d'histoire et des fois avec
avec une certaine maladresse
NiAl jusque-boutisme dans le fait de
vouloir jouer pour le gain par contre on
apprécie c'est louable mais quand on a
plus de temps des fois c'est plus sage
de faire nul je trouve que ça il a
raison il fait un super début de match
et qui rentre avec une petite nulle
donc à noter Sami qui est artiste
je crois qu'on peut en mettre tous ceux
qui arrivent
on commence à fatiguer son installation
mais il y en a pour encore trois heures
est-ce qu'on va parier sur les quarts de
finale du foot stuff je suis hyper
Chauvin donc autant dire que
si je devais vous donner le pronom le
prono gagnant pour la Coupe du Monde
c'est évidemment l'équipe de France qui
va gagner
avec beaucoup de buts d'Olivier Giroud
le truc le truc un peu hasardeux
d'ailleurs je profite de voir Samy dans
dans le chat parce que hier c'était
badminton comme vous le savez et je me
suis abonné j'ai refait mon premier
simple depuis un an tout fait j'ai fini
complètement carbonisé mais avec le
plaisir de la victoire et par contre en
équipe on a fait match nul seulement
voilà dans un petit derby qui nous
opposait au village voisin voilà voilà
les histoires bretonnes s'ouvrent comme
d'habitude voilà en tout cas c'était les
interclubs du coup c'était c'était les
interclubs et du coup j'ai gagné avec ma
compagne en mixte donc c'était plutôt
une bonne soirée voilà c'est pas tous
les jours
mais le contrat rempli on n'était pas
loin de gagner en plus donc c'est pas
c'était à moitié à moitié bon
mais à titre personnel pendant pendant
que ça se passait bien sur le cours de
base de l'autre côté NiAl mot frais mon
frère quelques subs sur le dos de stouf
et ça c'est bon quand même quand les
soirées se passent comme ça sera pas à
chaque fois cela est-ce que la disette
au niveau des subs c'était la disette ah
oui complètement complètement hier
c'était hallucinant
mais du coup
l'enchaînement ça fait mal
j'ai fait mes premières crampes Aubade
et pas aux échecs évidemment les échecs
c'est assez cool niveau crampe n'a pas
trop de problèmes
un pour une fois j'aime bien la position
de
qui a vraiment zéro risque parce qu'il
peut cibler pendant très longtemps le
Pione sauf pour une fois ça va être
ça va être normalement assez sympa pour
lui
d'ailleurs il l'a bien vu il est en
train de se focus dessus
il n'y a pas vraiment de contre jeu mais
c'est pas si simple parce que j'aime
bien placé je peux pas trop
et il est dur à enlever et en cas de
cavalier D1 C3
et B5 ou 2 à un moment tu sais pour te
l'enlever eux aussi de prendre en F5 et
de tripler sur E j'ai quand même plus de
perspectives je trouve
que tu as plus de perspectives et que ce
pion c'est un une faiblesse à long terme
mais c'est pas si simple de vraiment en
profiter parce que ce qu'avait il est il
est vraiment embêtant bah tiens il a
mangé d'ailleurs il a mangé pour tripler
sur eux un moment faut faire gaffe aux
fiancer de 1 comme sauf nous a dit
il va mettre une tour en cadre
vraisemblablement
voilà c'est fait et on met on met toutes
les toutes nos forces sur eux au moins
nos pièces lourdes déjà
et on peut faire un peu
le tourniquet
pour c'est quand même un petit pressing
cette pause
mais il y a toujours cavalier G5
en tout cas c'est une position qu'il
peut jouer beaucoup plus vite que
d'habitude et ça ouest les sauts de
réfléchir parce qu'il y a pas de
perspective pour les Noirs attention
quand même vous savez que ça peut se
retourner sur toi c'est cadences là mais
il va passer normalement à sale moment
ouais c'est d'ailleurs les moins à
l'aise autant alors qu'il avait montré
qu'il était très rapide et voyez à nous
ça t'auras qui a fait cavalier 3 kg 4
qui pourrait revenir en C4 vous voyez
des fois ces positions là il fait ce
qu'il veut
pas pressé
et il va juste voilà ma présence sur le
pion sur le pion ici le pion le 5 mais
j'ai toujours pas comment je vais faire
pour mettre la troisième pièce
c'est pas facile
en équipe de France avec les jeunes
c'était tourné pour gagner qu'on avait
appelé cela et là faut faire souffrir
souffrir l'adversaire
ok donc là dame j'ai trois faut regarder
mais il y a peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut faire dames ici pour
tenir la boutique je pense pas que ça
soit cahier des cartes à cause de cahier
prend un 5 qui est la dame mais dames G6
c'est le coup pour tenir voilà et
maintenant
est-ce qu'un échange de dames peut être
intéressant pour le noir sachant que je
suis en train de souffrir je pense que
oui sauf je sais pas là je suis autant
jusque là j'avais vu c'était normal
voilà damage 4 c'est ah oui de toute
façon il y a toujours le pressing c'est
à dire qu'il y a pas cavalier des quatre
comment on progresse ok H3 ça évite tous
les matchs du couloir et c'est pas un
gros ça faitblissement la cage G3 c'est
pas trop grave crois H2 c'était pour
verrouiller la 4G3 on comprend et
maintenant toujours plus facile à jouer
on a plus trop trop de coups
toujours on peut surveiller le petit F4
qui pourrait de le détonateur dans ces
positions là mais il est pas facile à
placer pour l'instant ok on va revenir
peut-être de l'autre côté pour voir
c'est vraiment dur de progresser parce
qu'on parle
de tourner pour gagner un tourniquet
très intéressant il est venue en G4 voir
un petit peu il améliore un petit peu la
position il va rebouger sa dame
vraisemblablement
il surveille quand même d'un point si F4
à tout moment ça peut être une
opportunité un astouffe de changer la
position qui ne gagne pas d'un point F6
pour une fois m'intéresse plus que tout
à l'heure
il y avait F4 bon il a pas voulu ah il y
avait F5 encore donc ça marchait pas
en tout cas un moment faudra y passer ça
y est il revient westero avec le
cavalier en D4 il va alterner entre la
défense du Pione 5
et le travail sur la faiblesse adverse
il empêche
je peux te voir
qu'elle avec son H5 on a des petits
guilis cavaliers dessin mais est-ce que
c'est fort utile non alors cette 3 c'est
un coin intéressant cavalier prend B3 il
a enfermé sans doute
préparer stouf tu sais pour empêcher ces
quatre on vous montre rapidement sur ça
et peut-être C4 suivi de qu'avec un
petit ordinateur ici je sais pas ce
qu'il dit mais il avait l'air de dire je
pense que on peut le bloquer tu sais
avec un tour C4 ou kfc4 c'est logique
donc bon ça a été joué très très vite à
ce niveau là on revient en direct et
directement le pressing continue il a
accepté d'avoir la faiblesse
en prise il a plus qu'à Z3 donc il y a
des trois mais tu as pas trop le temps
d'aller le chercher à chaque fois donc
je pense quand même toi tu peux mettre
c'est vraiment pas mal ce qui
surtout que vous voyez il y a pas
beaucoup de temps et on voit qu'à ce
niveau là il joue très très bien
stratégiquement même avec peu de temps
il préparait F4
F4 j'ai 3 3 pièces sur E7 c'est pas
assez donc on prépare on fixe
et c'est vraiment sympa
c'est rendu un progresser un je sais pas
comment on peut on peut faire il faut
tourner encore et encore dame j'ai trois
peut-être un moment l'échange de dames
serait une solution est-ce qu'il va
amener son roi jusqu'en A3 non en eux
deux c'est bien
c'est magnifique il profite si vous
voulez de la fixation qu'il a créé et là
il est en train de faire une Master
Class franchement la partie
exceptionnelle il va mettre toutes les
pièces correctement et il pourra jouer à
un moment projet 4
qui n'existait pas tout à l'heure et le
roi noir pouvait pas se transférer à
l'aile d'arme à cause du Pione 5 il
pouvait pas venir en E6 par exemple là
il y avait F4 à surveiller waouh c'est
beau
[Musique]
nous dit bonjour en italien et qui les
gens qui répondent en moitié espagnol
en russe du coup les gars je crois qu'on
est rendu international sur la chaîne
prise
je commence à connaître le style de
raisin qui est quand même recentré sur
la tactique tu vois il se régale
exactement
[Musique]
très très malin raisonne comme joueur
très pratique mais là on a on assiste
vraiment à une partie d'école
stratégique où il y a une grosse grosse
pression il la mérite mais après ouais
c'est ça il n'égrate pas sa position
pour autant il reste dans le match
est-ce que je sais que pour se créer un
petit pion passé protéger et intéressant
au hashis direct et chaque ça marchait
aussi avec la fourchette en G5
alors est-ce que maintenant j'ai des
finales de j'avais des final potentiel
de tout avec un peu plus il a préféré
damage cap si garde le pressing encore
c'est énorme bientôt peut-être des dames
G5 mais 6 encore
attention de ne pas prendre 5 bêtement
un peu un petit peu difficile qui vient
de faire là il va se prendre le gros con
et tout machin qui peut arriver
attention à moi il y a encore tout hein
mais
très dangereux
ça commence à être vraiment une grosse
[ __ ] attention parce que
cahier des deux de Damas et c'est des
problèmes
il va il est en train de se faire
retourner il a totalement contrôlé la
position et la position en train de le
glisser entre les doigts on fait une
partie une partie à mettre dans les
bouquins c'est dommage
et là il est en train il est en train
d'accuser le coup
il va pas la perdre ça va être match nul
je pense va y avoir des grandes
liquidations
contre le Pione mais ça va être un peu
juste pour
pour
ouais
cette position
[Musique]
de passer pour les deux joueurs
voilà il vient ici et bien joué
attention l'avantage est en train de
grandir le roi si le roi blanc venait à
s'infiltrer là je crois qu'il va gagner
finalement
je suis en train de changer
de pronostics attention est-ce que c'est
5 c'est jouable non il y a des 5
des 5 simplement là ça a l'air très très
pénible
vous comprenez
non franchement grosse partie petite
frayeur à un moment donné mais ça c'est
complètement retourné le en fait il
avait fait une partie d'école et le fait
plus avoir de temps il n'a pas plus
sécurisé son gain et on est à la pause
tout feu j'ai pas vu le temps passer
extraordinaire je vais la garder pour
mes courses celle-là
rarement vu une partie aussi bien
dominée stratégiquement 5 + 1 voilà
partie la première partie de wesleo
était aussi extraordinaire
il y avait eu plus d'erreurs là c'était
vraiment une petite faiblesse en E5 et
on tourne on tourne on tourne c'est
quand même vraiment assez assez
intéressant
dans tous les cas nous là on va passer
en pause les joueurs sont partis en
pause on va revenir dans trois quatre
minutes exact et pour dire salut à
Hector aussi et oui je sais que ma
petite doudoune elle fait fureur
je devrais la vendre sur mon site
c'est un pull en fait tu nous a dit hier
c'est pas du tout une veste c'est une
sorte de pull
c'est une veste pull hyper bien hyper
bien
ok ok du coup bah on vous retrouve tout
de suite vous savez c'est la pause de mi
5 + 1 voilà de moitié de 5 + 1 donc à
tout de suite restez parmi nous un trois
quatre minutes ayant revient à tout de
suite exactement salut à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour pour
Kevin n'est pas encore de retour mais va
arriver pour la suite de ce premier set
en 5 + 1 donc 2 et demi à 1 et demi pour
l'instant pour Wesley sauts qui aura les
blancs dans cette première partie et
donc un match quand même s'annonce assez
excitant avec une grosse grosse partie
de App Store off à l'instant alors
pourquoi est-ce que la partie va être
annulée on ne sait pas
que se passe-t-il
entre les joueurs
je vois les commentaires de l'Arabie
saut qui vient de se mettre une petite
une petite couette sur les genoux
avec un truc de fou sur l'installation
c'est trop marrant quoi c'est trop drôle
dans ce match c'est le but d'une heure
alors donc italienne un peu comme tout à
l'heure on a eu
jamais à leur cave professionnel salut à
toi j'espère que tu vas bien
qui est ici
je pense qu'il est parti au bar
peut-être pour ça qu'il est pas encore
revenu
alors cavalier H7 a été joué et donc
encore le plan peut-être de
jouer avec le 5 ici
la balance salut François
quand on parle d'apéro les gars François
arrive direct quand on parle d'apéro
Françoise sur le premier arrivé 6
comment est-ce qu'on continue ici ce
petit pion isolé qui peut poser problème
un jour
cavaliers le fou
faut trois cavaliers B4 attention au
petit trou sur casse blanche je suis en
retour 5 avec un balai prend à deux
gênant est-ce que c'est un coup pour
empêcher pour empêcher les cavaliers ces
deux
parce que j'ai quand même qu'à avalé des
trois qui pose problème aussi donc je
pense toujours il y a un coup
intéressant qui me qui m'interpelle
est-ce que ton tour pourrait pas faire
le bouton F3
suivi d'une idée comme peut-être
cavalier 5 pour attaquer un petit peu
les pions H3 et F3 je sais pas si c'est
possible du tout en tout cas mais ça a
l'air assez intéressant
salut Kevin on a repris sans toi
incroyable incroyable je vais me faire
une petite tisane tu sais à l'ancienne
plus sympa à boire je me suis dit bon il
est parti
tu vois à l'ancienne en me disant voilà
il faut préserver sa gorge dans ces
moments-là quoi et j'étais loin de
penser que j'avais raté la pause tu
voulais faire comme comment sa petite
tasse
ouais je me suis dit ouais pour le
souvenir mais j'ai une j'ai une tasse
plutôt tahitienne j'ai l'impression
voilà
non mais si vous avez envie de voir un
coup pas de souci n'hésitez pas mais moi
pour l'instant c'est la petite infusion
tu me diras François ce que ça donne du
coup ça m'intéresse
ça m'intéresse
cavalier de 5h c'est un coup que j'aime
bien qui va arriver alors je pense c'est
logique les casoirs sont vraiment
faibles chez les Blancs et du coup il
veut s'emparer de se fout de casse
blanche éventuellement après l'échange
ça me prend ramener un cavalier d'être
un jour en G6 peut être une bonne idée
en tout cas même pour le contrôle de
casse c'est intéressant et c'est bien de
faire pousser c'est important
et le professeur et je vois que toi
aussi tu as remarqué cette ouais ce
fameux pull que tout le monde m'envie tu
vois ce stuff reste plus plus que le les
parties quoi c'est incroyable quoi
franchement ça fait combien depuis hier
au moins 10 personnes qui te tournent
avec ça sur le sur le pull je me suis
senti obligé de le remettre en plus du
coup tu vois
pour voir
la pause et ben il s'est mis une
couverture sur les sur les sur les
jambes exactement
de jeu de sauts c'est hallucinant qu'il
arrive à jouer aussi vite aussi bien
dans ces conditions alors sauf les gars
il est assis sur une chaise en bois posé
qui doit avoir qui doit avoir je sais
pas déjà pas mal d'années parce que
et ensuite il est il a l'ordinateur
portable qui est posé sur la chaise
d'ordinateur sur la chasse de bureau et
il a la souris qui a à peu près
10 CM2
[Musique]
de place pour pour manœuvrer et
il est courbé le dos courrovelation sur
son ordinateur parce que bah il est il
joue vraiment enfin on dirait enfin il a
un truc de fou tu as l'impression qu'il
est
[Musique]
elle était pas mal celle-là de moi j'ai
une bouillotte j'ai bien aimé
[Rires]
il y a pas de il y a pas de
[Musique]
en tout cas il a bossé il a changé de
variante il me semble-t-il Abdou par
rapport à tout à l'heure il a du boulot
de notation et du coup
un choix payant parce qu'il avait été
vraiment en difficulté avec les noirs
sur sur l'italienne
tout le monde le voit mais il y aura le
retour de bâton tour B8 cavalier prend
F3 et puis on D4 il va voler avec des
perspectives sur les cases noires et
attention à la casse blanche sont un peu
faible mais les cases noires
on a presque
c'est quoi la raison
en tête il faut prendre des cartes qui
va qui va arriver on prend des cartes il
y a pas de coups en fait
on élimine le défenseur
[Musique]
et excuse d'apprendre F2 celui d'en
prendre E3 en tout cas c'est plus le
même joueur tout à l'heure on avait un
Wesley so hyper rapide qui voyait tout
et là il est beaucoup plus lent et il
s'est pris quand même une tactique
abordable quand même c'est clair
genre de mec qui blender quasiment
jamais
c'est vrai il est solide et
pas trop quoi et là pour le coup ben là
cette partie c'est pas c'est pas du
génie hein
faut faire gaffe quand même de pas se
prendre une
une contrepointes
sans se prendre la tête
A4 H4 je comprends pas
justement
le contre jeu sur la case blanche pour
pour taper son adversaire ok la boîte
foutue c'est pas simple
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est clair encore
de faire un coup comme G6 d'un projet 6
dans G7 en retour
mais ça a l'air pas mal de faire prendre
le fou en fait dans mes trois enfants
prise tu manges là mais peut-être j'ai 6
c'est rien du tout hein
ouais ça j'ai prévu dans ma psy c'est
terminé je reste sur la diago de qualité
de plus
que j'ai pas vu mais bon ça a pas l'air
non plus de
H4 peut-être donc du coup
et après
c'est pas mal parce qu'après c'est plus
rien du tout
[Musique]
internet
défensif par contre il est malin quand
même vous avez vu parce que si on
faisait tout de suite peut-être qu'on se
faisait arnaquer ce souffle le mec il
claque quand même d'abord en F3 c'est
bon là maintenant ça va être vidéo
et du coup il a sacrifié latence au
cavalier il avait deux qualités de plus
donc je peux en donner une pour
terminer et puis en plus il y a même
manger G5 donc il va forcer F4
Tamar il y a plus de maths
[Musique]
bientôt bientôt fini mais faire un petit
peu gaffe
donc deux et demi à deux et demi dans ce
premier set
la technique de mes poulins aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est au fond on laisse les
deux premiers tu vois comme dans les
parcs qu'on fidélise d'abord et après et
après on agresse le client quoi
c'est
un très très gros client ah oui oui
c'est certain mais ça fait bien plaisir
quand même
à chaque fois je fais un peu dans mon
froc on va pas on va pas se mentir
trop facile pour ça et la dernière là il
est c'était l'ombre de lui même par
rapport à ce qu'il a fait en début de
match ça fait trois parties d'affilée
qu'il ne gagne plus
mais les deux dernières en plus sont
vraiment mal placé donc
dans la troisième partie et
depuis par contre c'est plus le même
joueur abdosa Torah il est beaucoup
mieux et les brillant maman on a vu je
sais pas si professionnel est toujours
là mais lui qui aime bien le jeu
stratégique franchement
la partie précédente la partie d'école
qu'il a fait Abdou sa torov avec les
pièces blanches elle a montré dans
toutes les écoles c'est ce que Resan
nous a dit alors qu'il est vraiment
joueur tactique et il était il était
ébloui et nous aussi franchement partie
à montrer pour le sujet tourné pour
gagner mais tu sais à l'époque moi
j'étais un joueur hyper tactique
maintenant je me suis un peu posé avec
la file d'or tout ça mais à l'époque
c'était un vraiment hyper tactique et
quand je voyais une Master Class
professionnel comme ça c'était pour moi
beaucoup trop trop beau et en fait bon
tu as deux types de parties qui sont
belles tu avais parti hyper tactique
t'as tout sacrifie etc et c'est joli
mais aussi une partie de positionnelle
bien menée c'est aussi quelque chose qui
est à voir c'est la classe quoi et moi
j'étais toujours hyper impressionné et
je trouvais sur le parti tu arrives à
jouer contre le pur isolé ou tu arrives
à profiter de mes faiblesses etc à
tourner comme il a fait là par exemple
juste voir
la beauté dans toute cette dans toutes
ces parties et franchement
cette partie là
alors peut-être que ça parle pas
mais en fait il faut vous rendre compte
à quel point il a gagné sans donner
aucun contre jeu et la facilité la
technique avec laquelle il a réussi à
mener cette partie c'est juste
absolument
c'est pas vrai il se passe pas rien
à chaque fois il se passe des choses et
la potion qui s'améliore etc enfin c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment la classe quoi
puis la notion de poser des problèmes à
l'adversaire aussi donc ça c'est
vraiment intéressant et tu verras
professeur que il y a une petite erreur
à moins d'Abdou dans l'extrême zynote
qui a relancé
wesleo avant qu'il gagne la finale
et bon ça c'est le côté un petit peu
dommageable de la cadence mais sinon la
partie était quasiment parfaite vraiment
incroyable incroyable et là F5 stouf
dans cette partie pas mal les Blancs
avaient un petit plus
tu fais comme sens qu'il est stable tu
vois et
là du coup c'est assez intéressant parce
que du coup il peut
avoir un petit peu mais
quasiment prise
et j'aime beaucoup l'idée de F5 en tout
cas ça pose de grosse question en
pratique
ce qui tire la langue à la caméra
qui nous tirent la langue j'espère que
qu'il a vu qu'il voit des choses
aujourd'hui qui me fait peur c'est le
tour avec dessin qu'à la fin je crois
que oui oui c'est ça c'est la partie
avec le cavalier C4 qui repart en E3
puis en G4 pas exactement et qui revient
mais c'est ça professionnel et cette
partie elle est juste extraordinaire
même si un petit moment il lâche un peu
mais honnêtement c'est top c'est 4
coûter très intéressant de la part
d'abdos à torov mais il se prend quand
même une suite un peu critique prise au
cas dans le 4 x 5
oblige l'échange de dames
grâce à ce super coif 5 l'ouverture des
cases blanches il a réussi à faire un
petit peu des jouets Abdou ça aura
l'air facile pour les blancs mais au
final maintenant un super coiffe 5
j'aime beaucoup prise
des 4 et 5
un petit peu les cases blanches
est-ce que je suis forcément
sinon il perdait la pièce et après il va
juste des 5 j'aime bien ce qu'il fait
j'aime bien ce qu'il fait
et puis on joue aux échecs avec BK
on pourra jouer plus tard si on a envie
j'aime bien le coup jouer d'ailleurs par
parabdosa torov qui voit que la
structure est légèrement favorable
donc on peut attendre on peut jouer le
tour c'est deux tours C1
des fois peut-être manger rentrer de la
tour etc il a le temps il prend son
temps
d'ailleurs prend bien ton temps pour
être pour perdre votre temps d'ailleurs
ouais ouais ouais là c'est faux pas
déconner ce truc là tu as bien raison je
vous rappelle qu'on a qu'on a des paris
en fait sur ce match c'est pour ça
que du coup moi je suis pour ça et Kevin
est pour pour App Store et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je recommande à bien
prendre son temps pour à la fin gâcher
niveau spectaculaire c'est incroyable à
ce niveau là c'est le meilleur là pour
le coup je pense que c'est quand même
pas pareil je pense que
il est pas pareil
en tout cas il fait pas n'importe quoi
dans la finale parce qu'en terme de de
placement de pièces il va peut-être
mettre le cavalier en E3 le fond G3 et
c'est quand même un peu pénible pour les
Noirs peut-être pas grand chose quand
même mais bon
pour essayer de fixer un peu la position
pour faire autre chose mais les blancs
ah bah ils prennent leur temps et comme
ça on l'a dit une prise et Tours 7
a commencé à être pénible c'est pour ça
que du coup les blancs sont pas pressés
à faire c'est ça quand beaucoup de monde
aurait joué ces cinq tempos
plus amateur bien sûr
même un coup comme des fois BK
prix C4 c'est dangereux donc il fait
tout ces trois pour faire tourcer je
pensais qu'il y avait peut-être pris un
KTB 5 mais bon en fait
5 avec gain de temps mais bien sûr il
veut pas il veut pas figer pour
l'instant il considère qu'il va faire
tourner et va rentrer
dans cette position oui c'était le sens
du jeu c'était le sens de ce qu'il avait
produit précédemment
alors en train d'obtenir le petit plus
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi et
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs dis-toi que c'est
plutôt l'inverse généralement malgré les
apparences quand on faisait tu sais à
l'époque l'état d'un style etc je
prenais toujours les cookies les jeunes
quand toi tu prenais les plus forts et
là dans ce speechestre Kevin à chaque
fois me disait ouais mais c'est mon
compagnon d'équipe ouais mais c'est mon
croyant d'équipe
en fait j'ai pas vraiment choisi c'est
tout jusqu'à présent je subis un peu les
éléments
parce qu'en fait ok il y a eu quoi comme
match qu'on a commenté ensemble il a
raté B5 là maintenant il va se faire il
va se faire coincer
alors on a commenté aronia oui
moi j'ai choisi parce que je pensais que
bon c'est favori
en fait j'ai eu deux collègues de clubs
qui jouaient et plus après le 3e tu as
choisi donc et là du coup comme j'ai
choisi mes deux collègues de club les
deux autres Paris j'ai pas choisi pour
la sauce a été très simple donc du coup
j'ai on a enfin j'ai subi aussi parce
que je t'ai laissé quand même je l'ai
choisir mais pour le coup eyes j'aurais
choisi aussi et après tu as eu qui
j'aurais choisi si ça arrive
et donc bon en fait dans les dans les
deux cas j'aurais choisi comme toi donc
non je suis pas d'accord avec cette
série là ça c'est juste
c'est comme ça mais c'est pas ce que tu
crois
c'est terrible cette position c'est plus
quoi jouer côté avec cette douce petite
seconde il est en train de perdre pierre
puis ça t'auras il a fait toute la
partie devant ouais
il est hyper solide et malgré tout il
faut passer et en fait non mais il a été
trop gourmand autant tu l'annonçais
d'ailleurs tof et tu as été tu as été
bon là-dessus
et là la position quand même plus facile
pour les noirs et surtout c'est une
minute contre 6 secondes donc il va
essayer là et
plus agréable il a rendu un peu de
contre jeu ça devrait le faire quand
même pour Wesley
il a maintenant un pion passé en B
et une question
il va y avoir un truc j'ai pas vu mais
ah sur Tours C8 attaquer le fou il y a
eu prise en dessin intermédiaire parce
qu'il y avait le four en prison
[Musique]
il peut être un peu légitimement déçu
mais je crois qu'il a vraiment perdu
cette partie autant quoi
ici il a pas peur et c'est perdu
donc ceux qui repasse devant au
classement
dans ce genre de position c'est pas
comme on dirait qu'il joue vraiment très
peu de Bullet c'est un site
en fait il est hyper solide et c'est un
joueur qui je vais pas dire qu'il
blender jamais parce que il a blender et
blender très très peu et il est il est
très constant en fait et même si les
mâles il va tenir tenir tenir et c'est
vraiment difficile de de
basse au quoi donc sur un match comme ça
je pense que vraiment un saut est
et favoris quand même
[Musique]
il pouvait attendre peut-être avant de
prendre des cartes
ok
là on a une position un peu plus plate
que d'habitude les Blancs n'ont pas
obtenu grand-chose
mais il vient de faire fouder 4 qui a
accélère le développement le
développement blanc alors qu'il pouvait
peut-être attendre un sauf comme tout à
l'heure on peut le même motif
ouais ouais c'est toujours toujours des
beaux matchs en tout cas ouais je suis
bien d'accord solide clairement
bon hélas c'est quand même un petit peu
plus embêtant côté noir on manque un peu
d'espace
c'est le jeu avec les Noirs un petit peu
plus compliqué le dernier coup est
intéressant pour les joueurs amateurs
c'est vraiment voir fou d'eux j'ai
l'avantage central E4 contre D6 au
niveau de la structure donc on garde les
pièces c'est le genre de jolis coups on
aurait pu penser à des fous B5 aussi
pour provoquer des fois des C6 mais il
rufoud et ça et voilà maintenant on
valorise le centre on a plus d'espace
donc on garde les pièces le four viendra
peut-être en F3 en fait ce que ça de
voir c'est que les Blancs jouent comme
sur quatre rangées pour un prix noire
pour arranger donc vu qu'on a plus
d'espace et ben il faut qu'on garde les
pièces parce que les Noirs en fait ils
ont pas assez d'espace pour toute leur
pièce donc laissez-les avec ce manque
d'espace donc garder les pièces si on
échange les pièces ça va quand même
vachement faire de la faire des noirs
on est vraiment dans le jeu
d'amélioration et de restriction du jeu
adverse c'est Xavier ça dans son livre
La Boussole sur l'échiquier nous parler
de jeux pour maths je pour la promotion
ou je pour la restriction et là on est
typiquement dans le fait de bloquer
l'adversaire sur les trois rangées comme
nous disent tous
et du coup c'est dur c'est dur à
supporter et petit à petit bin les Noirs
ne sachant plus quoi jouer ils peuvent
détruire eux-mêmes leur position
d'ailleurs le dernier coup c'est 6 ben
c'est affaiblissant pour D6 même si il
le fait pour jouer des 5 sans doute
il ne peut pas le faire maintenant
j'ai pensé d'un B6 qui est cette dame
[Musique]
[Rires]
le trail positionnel
la petite rentrée
merci pour ton pour ton message
[Musique]
non je pense que en fait ok il a fait le
tournoi enfin il a fait un super tournoi
je peux la du monde
il y a beaucoup de monde et ça joue
vachement à la forme donc là dans ce
champion du monde il a été peut-être le
joueur plus en forme et c'est pour ça
qu'il a gagné mais du coup il y a pour
moi il y a trop de très bons joueurs
dans ce dans ce genre de compétition
pour qu'il regagne une deuxième fois il
y a que les cars scènes Nakamura qui
sont au-dessus du lot pour moi dans les
cadences très rapides bon pour 45 c'est
en l'an bien évidemment bien sûr qu'il
est aussi très dominant
mais Nakamura et l'autre joueur qui
encadance rapide peut largement
concurrencer Carlsen et du coup il y a
que ces deux joueurs là je pense qu'ils
peuvent être régulier à très très haut
niveau dans les cadences rapides à
monstre son engagement
rapide bah ça m'étonne pas
ça m'étonne beaucoup quand même bon une
fois déjà c'est pas mal mais encore une
fois tu vois même un makamura
en fait pourquoi pas tu vois mais là
c'est vrai que c'est plus étonnant il a
fait un support pour moi il a clairement
mérité c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout un plot hein mais
vu son jeune âge
d'affilée ça me paraît quand même en
tout cas même si il vient de gagner la
côte pour qu'il gagne deux fois va être
énorme
va être énorme
donc je vais pas rire pas sur lui en
tout cas d'ailleurs Kevin
on va être on en a parlé hier mais
Kevin et moi comment t'auront le les
rapides de Blitz qui se déroule je sais
plus où d'ailleurs je crois que c'est au
Kazakhstan si je dis pas de bêtises
Kazakhstan ouais et j'ai oublié la ville
parce que c'est loin de la Bretagne au
stuff
c'est pas Antalya
non c'est hier j'ai vu l'info j'ai été
regardé mais j'ai déjà oublié quoi la
vie est dure mais en tout cas j'ai les
dates
c'est 26 27 28 décembre
voilà
almati mais
c'est vrai qu'elle m'a dit
elle m'a dit merci
[Musique]
et du coup donc toujours le travail
autour du pion des 6 et plus d'espace
par contre
c'est souvent ce qui se passe derrière
dans les espagnols italiens ou en fait
et ben
on tape sur des 6 mais c'est jamais
simple parce qu'il y a aussi 5 qui
grosses décisions là de Wesley Sow
rapidement
[Musique]
c'est ce qui sont en train de calculer
les joueurs et on voit fait obligé de
calculer dans cette position cette suite
avec fou B7 et EF4
et c'est bizarre je trouve pas en tout
cas et tout en prise
dans le prise 5
tours D8 et reprise en E5 c'est jouable
j'ai pas relevé mais bon vu que tu
insistes bon oui oui on va dire
Dame des trois sur F4 oh bravo regarde
professionnel il nous a fait un très
joli calcul stuff
Dame des trois et là c'est la petite
pointe et attention professionnelle
calcul comme OS tu as vu ce petit dame
D3 avec la Dame des 8 en l'air et sur
dame prend des trois cas et prendre les
trois protège la tour 1
c'est la partie et si la France du coup
ça paraît clair Adam des trois je peux
encore aller attaquer le fouet sans
doute
donc c'est la partie en plus
professionnel bienvenue
mais c'est compliqué quand même cette
position malheureusement il est trop mal
au temps
ce qu'il arrive plus jamais à avoir
assez de jeu
il a été plus loin que moi le jeune
après mais il a pas encore été assez
loin pas aussi loin en tout cas que que
qui a été très dominant jusqu'à 2
minutes ça tenait bien deux minutes deux
minutes mais là malheureusement
son saut qui part à deux et qui passe à
deux barres de connexion
son ordi c'est le bon moment en tout cas
Wesley de nous régaler
pour le bêtisier
[Musique]
et
ça va être ça va être 4 4 2 4 et demi
dans ce premier
minute restant je pense qu'une dernière
partie sera jouée c'est les deux sables
qui s'envolent et on voit
ouais ça dépend avant il pouvait
peut-être faire mieux et pas c'était pas
si clair mais la position d'avance un
peu c'est un peu vrillé
il peut pas s'exprime partout
[Musique]
bon en tout cas voilà là c'est mieux les
positions qu'il obtient avec les Blancs
c'est toujours des petits pressings
quand même c'est avec les noirs pour
l'instant qu'il a pas réussi à trouver
à trouver les solutions
on voit un important d'avoir les blancs
dans les cadences rapides ultra rapide
pour mettre la pression directe et ça
compte beaucoup dès qu'on arrive à
mettre la presse
a forcément on est plus à la cool en
terme de temps et ça joue énormément
même à ce niveau là où les joueurs sont
très à droite même sous pression autant
des quatre
ouais bon un petit un petit plus blanc
d'espace et agréable à jouer et puis
voilà quoi alors du coup faut toujours
calculer cavaliers prend un cadre dans
ses positions touffe bon ça paraît ça
paraît un peu limite elle est positions
un peu marcher
[Musique]
qui sera le dernier à manger
fais attention à ça peut arriver et
sosley qui qui encore une fois à deux
barres de connexion internet ça me fait
un petit peu peur
j'espère pour le bulle en tout cas il va
il va être il va être rapide hein
on a vu on a vu 45
contre bouquet qui a des frais de
connexion
23,7 avec des problèmes de connexion
heureusement qu'il en avait
non mais il a eu des problèmes de
connexion deux fois en fait il a duré la
boxe
j'avais proposé qui va presque forcé
d'ailleurs qui va forcer les changes de
l'âme
parce que il y a pas de case en fait là
ça m'offre une colonne ouverte à tout de
suite bloqué avec A4 RA subir un B5
B4 poser problème la paire de fou et du
coup le gain d'espace de ce côté là je
comprends pas j'ai 5 cavaliers H5 voilà
il a trouvé tout de suite pour les cases
noires je pense qu'il fallait jouer
plutôt F4 F4 pour fixer il a oublié je
pense à 120 parce que ça c'est vraiment
pénible c'est vrai que prise est juste
fou F4
B2
normal je pense pas qu'on soit pressé de
manger j'ai trois parce que le fou
s'envole pas et puis en plus après le
Cavalier Blanc viendra ici sur les cases
blanches peut-être juste fou f-6 alors
bien est-ce que parfois là c'est le
drame il est pas content du tout d'avoir
raté d'avoir raté de jouer F4 qui
empêchait cette possibilité de se faire
piquer
ça va être très très difficile de gagner
il faut pas la perdre déjà cette
position pour rester un petit peu dans
le match
que égaliser faire l'effort et ensuite
se prendre deux bulles d'Irak ça fait
mal
prise prise bon il y a de bonne chance
que ça s'attende vers la hauteur
hyper inquiétant
mais bon
[Musique]
à 8 ça peut ça peut être un petit peu
problématique un jour et la part de fou
bah elle a quand même là
on ne doit pas jouer F4 pour faire
quelque chose avec les Blancs c'est
compromettant mais
bien vu pas d'où ça te rend fait on y
prend plus ce qui est malheureusement
c'est la partie où ils se mettrai mal au
temps qui a fait briller voilà il joue
avec 4 c'est assez logique je pense pour
contraindre les fous on est toujours
dans le jeu de restriction
F2 tour des deux voilà c'est très bien
tour des deux
côtés on sait pas trop on veut mettre la
tour ou la Tour Eiffel en D1 mais en
tout cas c'est très souple au niveau des
tours
bien la boutique pour l'instant on peut
avoir aussi tout rêve 2 et E5
et surtout F2 tu veux jouer comment
assez vite
parce que je vois pas comment tu vas
défendre
on le joue allez et maintenant il y a
des E5 aussi
tu as pas le temps en fait et parfois je
sens que j'ai 4 fois il y a F5
G4 faut prendre 4 puis on prend des 4
faut prendre
[Musique]
G400 même cavaliers
on défend on défend ici et maintenant du
coup sur un prix dans la 5 je vais tout
prendre il y aura
mais j'ai pas le droit
enfin j'ai pas le droit
4 et quand même un problème
il est revenu ce bien c'est c'est
pragmatique
tourner
4 minutes dans ce temps réglementaire
pour la première phase de jeu
et avec beaucoup d'avance sur sur ce
cabine je pense qu'on peut dire que
c'est quasiment fini à moins que cette
partie se terminent rapidement par une
victoire de photographe et qui puisse
enchaîner du coup sur une deuxième
victoire rapidement avant que le temps
arrive à zéro mais ça m'a l'air
compliqué parce que cette police là tu
vois je la vois quand même pas trop se
terminer
avant le temps réglementar il reste
trois minutes 50 et les deux jours
il n'y a pas de risque particulier pour
les Noirs à part le temps là 40 secondes
de moins mais il faut que il y a pas de
plan non plus véritable et tout D8 ça
ressemble à une sorte de proposition de
nulle que
à 120 n'a pas envie de d'accepter
au vu du contexte du match
particulièrement où il est en retard
maintenant
mais c'est très très difficile il faut
jouer assez vite ces positions pour
pour mettre le pressing en place
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là du coup est-ce
qu'on joue
7 le coup mais il va se rendre E5 et F5
c'est bizarre je vois pas trop ce qu'il
a vu ça fait à une pièce non
j'ai raté mais bon c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez dégueu
peut-être trois rois quelque part plutôt
qu'à aider quatre pour avoir B4 ça va
forcer fouet 8 voilà c'est
vraiment une décision assez bizarre tout
fin qui est assez difficile à expliquer
ouais il s'est un petit peu perdu dans
la matrice
faire gaffe à ça
ils peuvent verrouiller lui-même ma
règle G4 et passer le roi en G3 sur des
H1 la partie
en tout cas Wesley sceaux après sa
bêtise il essaie oui parce qu'on voit
vraiment que on est un peu muselé côté
noir mais laisser d'embrouiller son
adversaire
bon fait aussi c'est tant pis si on se
prend un échec non
plus
mais c'est difficile de finir le ah oui
il y aurait un truc horrible
âgé et tout réussis non ça marchera pas
il faut F5 donc moi je crois savoir on
va retrouver la suite on va voir ce qui
se passe en tout cas tu peux vraiment
jouer sans réfléchir non mais le truc
c'est que maintenant ah il a joué j'ai
trois d'accord au cas où peut-être le
roi là est ton roi il est il est il est
bloqué il essaye
pas
ça peut être chaud mais ça va
normalement ça va ça a l'air bien
on voit pas du tout comment il pourrait
changer les deux tours et on a gagné
c'est une position qui est très très
prometteuse pour pour en tout cas un
petit Rohff alors qu'il reste
parce que on a vu il reste 40 secondes
mais avant ce sera pas assez pour venir
terminer la partie
B5
roi des 6
et des 4
ok pressing quand même sur C6 et là
perdu
bon contrôle des blancs dans la position
donc tour des 6 c'était le seul coup je
crois c'était obligatoire
et maintenant comment on finit parce que
j'arrivais pas à ok fou B3 il met les
pièces sur les bonnes cases mais c'est
pas facile de finir
il attend ah voilà il va passer les
tours en H je pense qu'il a joué tout E1
il reste 3 secondes dans ce temps et
c'est terminé du coup je t'annonce que
tu mets de plus et ça c'est ça je sais
bien je sais bien où tu voulais en venir
exactement et ça me fait mal parce que
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il y ait un petit
peu plus de de suspense avec une
repartie
là on est proche de l'abandon
ça va être abandon
je vois pas trop comment
attention à coup d'échec là et tu vois
que la paire de fou noir ne joue pas du
tout
[Musique]
allez allez attention temps
seconde ouh là là
x87 peut-être
c'est hyper chaud c'est très compliqué
il y a tout échec
ou pas il prend B5 la foi H5 qui doit
être fort
quand même dans cette histoire ici
non le prénom
dommage
finalement je reste
c'est quand même bon il a plus de temps
la pendule je comprends mais eux il a
pris mauvais il a pris mauvais E8 dames
et il pensait que c'était obligatoire il
y a d'où ça t'auras pendant ce temps-là
qui parle tout seul de cette victoire ça
a été chaud vous avez vu sur la fin
c'était ils sont pas encore ils sont pas
encore en mode Bullet non et c'était
on sort pas si mal quand même côté ça a
failli briller quand même
bon quand même les deux sœurs sont
prises il y a que un point d'écart donc
ça reste encore très très chaud dans ce
dans ce dans ce premier set
moi je pense c'est ça donc on va faire
une petite page de pub on se retrouve
dans 5 minutes un peu moins de 5 minutes
avec Kevin du coup pour ce deuxième set
on va avoir une heure de trois plus une
25 accélérer maintenant je souffre voilà
une heure de trois plus Sud ça va aller
plus vite ça va être plus sympa donc
ne partez pas et à tout de suite à tout
de suite à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour ce
deuxième set qui va démarrer à l'instant
entre
so Wesley avec les Blancs contre
bonjour à tous yes donc pour l'instant
le score est de 4,5 pour pour ce qui a
fait gagner bien sûr deux subs à notre
ami stuff je parle de toi la troisième
personne dommage et quand je pars la
troisième personne
honnêtement on a failli se retrouver à
plus trois là ok il y a plus un ça va
c'est raisonnable ça joue
et du coup il est encore en vie à tout
ça tu auras falloir que ça aurait pu
être très très compliqué il a dominé la
dernière partie la finale bon alors qu'à
un moment
clairement SSO a payé la bonne décision
stratégique pour revenir à niveau en
tout cas il gagne des points et l'autre
chez comme
il est plus de 3000 ce qui n'était pas
le cas au départ il va raser des points
de chasse comme là
clairement pas clairement pas
qu'ils en ont rien à battre
ah mais si rasent bien les points de
chasse comme ça veut dire que ça se
passe bien et c'est ce que j'espère
Google il a gagné 100 points hello dans
son match contre gars de scène mais
c'est pas très bien passé quand même
ouais clairement clairement pas c'est
pas un bon exemple pour moi après il a
commencé avec 2700 Elo ce qui était
vraiment très très maigre pour
[Musique]
pour
là on va envoyer 3 + 5 changements de
cadence vous voyez que tout est en train
de changer ça la technique au platine le
chrono tout ça
[Musique]
tout est tout est bon quasiment on a les
cames tout fonctionne de manière nickel
et oui ton guitare
ça commence ouh là à l'instant dans
quelques secondes dans quelques secondes
le 3 plus 1 arrive
et on a aidé bravo pour le Paris gagnant
je pense que tu fais référence à Hyères
effectivement
merci à toi merci à toi pour le soutien
et là tu vois j'ai laissé tout faire la
course en tête
avec son poulain Wesley sceaux ils sont
tombés dans le panneau en vrai
qui rappelle les joueurs ceux qui vient
de se lever
il a un plaid ah ouais non mais il est
il est commencé je pense qu'il avait pas
vu
c'est pas grave allez commençons assez
marrant sur la 3 et en plus il rit
peut-être si l'arrivée
c'est dingue c'est vraiment une
impression que ça peut donner
c'est franchement ça donne vraiment
l'impression pour après jouer qu'avalier
F3 et 4
bon maintenant c'est normal il y a pas
de problème après les deux
trois il est normal
tout est normal cette position DC5
devrait arriver voilà
on est dans la vigne il y a une partie
entre
entre Carlsen et Wesley Sow Wesley
pièces noires et du coup il connaît il
connaît bien ce genre de petits systèmes
j'avais perdu en 15 couches je crois que
c'était un speech d'ailleurs il y avait
pris un sale truc c'est toujours à ça
agréable c'est position on règle les
blancs
c'est très solide et très sympa
[Musique]
il est un peu surpris
je suis pas sûr qu'ils connaissent bien
avec les noirs et ses positions là on
peut vite se retrouver un petit peu
embête et après c'est du 3 plus 1
normalement je fous des trois tours
DC cavalier C et on a tous nos pièces
qui sont braquées vers
vers le petit gros petit robe noire on
peut avoir certains B5 des fois pour
gagner des cases attention il y a quand
il y a 5 qui peut être gênant mais on a
un jeu de pièces qui est quand même
favorisé dans cette position donc à et
C4 vraisemblablement
ça aurait été beaucoup mieux petit rock
au lieu de Tours c'est un peut-être dans
ces positions il aurait pu prendre du
cavalier en E5
pour provoquer GF3 et A5
ça c'est pas très bien passé là pour
non mais ça reste quand même
je pense
et je suis pas sûr que vous prenez F3
soit un bon coup en fait tu vois sur un
point c'est la partie
il y a la part de foot on voit bien
c'est peut utiliser la colonne g et
taper avec mes fous sur ton roi donc en
fait certes tu casses
le château je pense qu'il dit que c'est
égal quoi oui non ok mais en pratique je
trouve qu'il est quand même une petite
pression blanche dans celle-là parce que
là je vais récupérer probablement le
pion B et 6 malheureusement à cause de
fou prend
pas du coup
est-ce qu'on a tout à 5 ouais c'est ça
que je voulais jouer
ça va être assez assez plat ça peut
faire
m'avait habitué à du beau jeu là je sais
pas ce qui se passe donc
explique-moi ce que vous avez mis en
place à la pause
et nul direct
[Rires]
je crois que je crois que
sauve
tout blinder il va bloquer il veut
bloquer il veut bloquer et plus
permettre à Peter of de revenir dans ce
match donc fous des trois c'est c'est
hyper solides quand même pour les noirs
on va voir mais en tout cas c'est pas
passé grand chose dans cette première
partie 3 plus 1 alors des fois ça va
ça va très vite donc kbdo qui est
pression sur sur le Caval et hop on
rebascule de l'autre côté réponse et à
une Française d'échange hein
[Musique]
on est toujours un petit peu mieux ici
avec les Blancs parce que les pièces
sont plus jolies d'ailleurs il y a une
partie il me semble candidat entre un
épaumené à titre
sing avec des idées fous des 6 cavaliers
F5 peuvent être intéressantes
pour le cavalier en F5
sans doute jusqu'au bout
donc la structure elle a quand même très
solide pour les Noirs c'est symétrique
les Blancs ont un meilleur jeu de pièces
et plus de possibilités donc le but des
Noirs c'est essayer de changer les
pièces et essayer de
d'aplanir un peu cette position
bon par contre il faut jouer vite
Abdou sinon
on sait comment ça se passe ce genre de
position
on domine un petit peu et après ça
s'écrase
bien voulu qu'il joue autour de vous
d'ailleurs
très vite c'est dommage là il est pas
assez pratique par rapport à ce qu'ils
peuvent faire
voilà c'est mieux il faut faire
réfléchir l'adversaire dans ce type de
cadence
autour de toi on voit quand même que que
saut est à
balle de match d'arriver à d'arriver à 6
points
ce qui lui ferait un petit
saucisse excuse-moi j'adore les blagues
autour de autour de Sceaux
très très joli
des blagues un petit peu plus épineuses
là dessus mais blague qu'on connaît
depuis longtemps tu vois comme sodomie
tout ça mais on a eu on a eu dans
ces vieux tu vois alors que saucisse je
sais pas si facile
la bonne c'est de la bonne
c'était bon là c'était bon sauf moi
jouer le coup qui va permettre de faire
caille G4 on va faire de la normalement
c'est bon là c'est bon on a eu le on a
eu ce qu'il fallait ok
relief 5 ou H5 pour empêcher on peut pas
faire
emprise et des fois H6 mais quand même
tout à l'heure quand vous êtes solides
je vois pas trop trop un monde où ça
marcherait pour l'instant
ok donc ça marche absolument pas dommage
tout aussi du coup c'est pas simple pour
les blondes progresser hein franchement
regardez justement cavalier F7 à
cavalier hi sache mais bon KFC
donc ce manque de temps ça peut lui être
fatal à
[Musique]
dire hein
pour nous je préfère dire Abdou
plus facile plus simple
alors peut-être un petit cave à laisser
5 pour gagner la colonne travailler sur
le faux F6 la tour E6 cavalier F4 aussi
en option
et tout revit
parce qu'en fait il y a pas de faiblesse
alors que
j'ai l'impression que les pièces noires
sont un peu plus actives
tu vois le foot
et qu'après les échanges de pièces bah
écoute moi j'ai des ruptures là
il est mal au temps en plus c'est
surtout ça la problématique mais là il a
réussi il voulait je pense faire
cavalier aussi pour la structure
et ça et ça parce que je pensais
pas mal à moins qu'il y a un F3 qui
arrive un jour
dans ma fille tranquille
allez il faut jouer F3 sans doute
jouable non pas du tout cavalier 4 alors
non pas du tout non plus donc on attend
toujours
[Musique]
ok ce pion qui est un peu tabou au final
parce que il y a pas mal de faiblesses
attention la fourchette est-ce que c'est
un chapitre de livre le pion tabou le
pion tabou a été croqué
moi j'ai mangé à deux
huit peut-être dame
final
c'est un problème pratique là
même si il pense que la finale est
meilleur pour lui parce qu'elle a une
majorité de ce côté-là très bien joué je
crois parce que la majorité blanche à
pousser j'ai l'impression de la B54
[Musique]
ça va très vite
il pense qu'il va falloir manger B3 pas
stupide non plus ah il faut que ça prend
à 4 ou pas je pense qu'il faut manger à
4 quand même pour pas laisser pousser le
pion
et maintenant voir si on peut pousser
[Musique]
c'est pas une bonne partie ça va être
perdu là pour pour revenir en jeu
qui a beaucoup mieux gérer son temps là
encore on l'avait vu un certaines fois
c'est très très important
abandon de notre revershi
et on voit saucisse
fameuse saucisse prise rock à D4 d'abord
pour prendre la case enfin pour
provoquer des pions isolés chez
l'adversaire
salut Charles salut Charles
mais c'est un petit peu dommage
[Musique]
mais bon c'est quand même pas une bonne
idée quoi ça pose problème quand même
cette ce que même quand tu as un
incrément le fait d'avoir trois secondes
contre 20
ça joue beaucoup quoi tu peux plus
réfléchir quoi tu as plus le temps de
réfléchir et te poser de la je découvre
comme ça très rapide
il aurait pu poser des problèmes
pratiques de pas laisser au moins le
pion à la promo et là on voyait quoi
c'est encore tout à fait jouable il a
craqué c'est ça
[Musique]
vous voyez le cavalier le feu est en
l'air
et du coup on peut aller le prendre sans
doute
sans doute parce qu'avec un LG 4 mais il
y aurait cavalier F3 on ne variante
bon et puis c'est une position un petit
peu
c'est
[Musique]
équilibrés d'avance qui joue calme
et puis surtout il débit de les coups il
y a toujours une réflexion un petit peu
trop importante à un moment de la partie
souvent il arrive à tenir le choc au
début et Pam gros réflexion et ça
devient dur
et mettre le four en G3 j'avais déjà vu
plein de parties comme ça
et on regarde
à titre perso mais
je trouve que c'est plus simple à jouer
ah non mais les pièces sur les bonnes
cases on pose des petits problèmes
G3 sur E6 avec dessin rapide et tes
cartes tu sais ah oui ça ressemble
énormément et il y a beaucoup de de
structures comme ça ça se joue pendant
longtemps les structures hyper modernes
ouais et c'est intéressant parce qu'en
fait chacun à ses avantages
d'inconvénients là on voit que les dents
ont un problème avec le pion isolant de
5 mais ces pions là ce qu'on peut faire
et le 12 et 2
et si je fais ça ça va il risque de
récupérer cette case là donc si jamais
évident à jouer mais en tout cas c'est
hyper intéressant comme structure la
foule de manière cool
parce que ça empêche les éventuels et
puis on prépare en fait le fou à aller
derrière donc un G4 ça prend les cages
du cavaliers
3 et ça y est tu as le fiancé
ça c'est c'est hyper standard dans ces
poses de G4 je pense qu'il va le jouer
un G4 peut-être pas tout de suite qu'il
aura peur d'ouverture des cases noires
avec un petit food D6 par exemple
généralement c'est le coup qui est qui
est recommandé dans sa position
nouvelle fois
je vais pas mettre en T-shirt quand même
non non il fait bon mais c'est pas mal
de comment pour commenter il faut avoir
une tenue vous voyez Stéphane lui aussi
malgré la chaleur qui règne chez lui
dans ses contrées lointaines ensoleillé
il a quand même mis un petit pull lui
aussi vous voyez il sait pas ce qu'il
faut que ça c'est un peu bon enfin
contrairement à toi je pense que il fait
très chaud chez moi mais aujourd'hui la
météo proche de zéro à chaque fois moi
aujourd'hui il faisait entre eux alors
minimum 17
maximum 24 ok ok
[Musique]
chez moi et c'est c'est pas très désolé
et chez moi il fait un peu froid enfin
même pendant l'été il faisait frais donc
dans mon appartement
juste pour dormir un peu le ventilo des
fois mais sinon tranquille et du coup
ben là elle fait un petit peu frais
tranquille donc j'ai un petit pull
tranquille tu vois j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir la doudoune comme seau ou comme
travail très très beau travail il a
poussé rapidement son roi mais il
contrôle bien la position
c'est pas facile
sur le long terme on peut espérer une
consolidation il aurait pu espérer en
tout cas une consolidation avec des
trois et un jour faire G4
il est pressé et encore 30 secondes
d'avance c'est pas vrai c'est le speed
chasse là
l'Abdo il joue un peu dans mon style
c'est à dire que bah il joue il joue
correctement mais la problématique c'est
qu'il prend beaucoup trop de temps quoi
et ceux qui jouent plein de coups de
pratique assez vite
hier on parlait de de farine qui est qui
jouait très vite ces systèmes bizarres
ou en fait les pièces étaient vivantes
il y avait plein de choses à faire et ça
marche pas mal parce qu'il arrivait à
mettre la pression autant à guéri qui
dirige lui essayait de bien jouer aux
échecs et de faire de prendre les
meilleures décisions au niveau des
échecs et ben là tu vois que norbarque
et ben c'est c'est un peu même si que
guéri tu vois il est un peu à la
recherche de la vérité et les meilleurs
coups et pas que pratique tu vois il
faut vraiment manger
sur la franchement il fait une très très
jolie partie d'amélioration et
maintenant il va jouer un jour projet 4G
5 ça ressemble d'ailleurs un petit peu
au contrôle qu'a réussi à faire à Abdou
sa torov dans sa Master Class tout à
l'heure la partie qu'il a vraiment
dominé de bout en bout même s'il y a eu
un petit cafouillis à un moment et on a
on presse une faiblesse on musait les
pièces noires qui deviennent esclaves et
on balance G4 ça y est il commence à
percer c'est magnifique surtout à dans
cela de trois plus un est très très
belle encore cette partie Stéphane
que pièce 24 a été racheté par par
chiasse.com
oui ça fait partie exactement donc on
peut dire chaise 24 à la Greno c'est ça
je pense quand même pièce 24
je crois comment aussi cet événement qui
est cheescom d'accord j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient dans le dans le podcast en tout
cas
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait voir
sacrifice de pion enfin non attends
on essaie d'arnaquer à la place de
d'abdos à Torah fait on a trois secondes
contre 7 donc peut-être que on peut on
peut tenir parce que c'est un peu chaud
en termes de temps il veut mettre le
français
[Musique]
avec ton plaid et finalement je vais
être honnête super partie franchement
partie exceptionnel l'Ouest vous savez
que je
déjà un soutien d'effectif de d'abdosa
torov qui a franchement pris une raclée
dans cette partie là et qui a de la
chance d'avoir une technique qui est
quand même un peu plus en place que
wesleyko qui est en train de rebrancher
ses câbles comme vous le voyez à la
caméra qui est quand même pas si
satisfait de
c'est incroyable comme on dit si vous
voyez l'installation l'installation
de de saut et la et l'installation
je te le montre Kevin juste à toi mais
regarde juste l'installation de notre et
voilà
c'est juste d'aller complètement
hallucinant
et franchement
on n'a pas le droit de montrer Stéphane
c'est dommage parce que
j'ai pas la gamme pour enfin je l'ai pas
mis sur Obs et puis je sais pas après
c'est quand même chez eux on voit on
voit leur appartement on voit tout ça
mais juste pour dire à quel point il est
sur une belle table
c'est vrai que si on avait une
autorisation de de Robin faille par
exemple tu pouvais montrer tu vois avoir
une scène spéciale en grand tu sais pour
par moment montrer ça parce que attends
excuse-moi mais là les caméras ont bougé
chez moi
et et là vous voyez ça vous voyez sa
chaise j'ai rien fait j'ai rien fait
j'ai rien fait c'est pas ma faute
qui joue merci merci
sauf que je pouvais demander un truc et
que ça se produise c'est ouf non en fait
les caméras les gars les caméras ont
changé c'est son chargeur sur le zoom je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé sur le zoom
mais du coup ça tout un tout changé du
coup bah je vais vous changer je vais je
vais vous remettre les caméras il est
avachi parce qu'en fait comme il joue
sur une chaise bah la chaise est pas
assez haute du coup il se penche dessus
et voilà comment il a perdu sa partie
dans l'ultra zenat même s'il est revenu
à deux barres de connexion sauf nous là
un peu prédit mais pas trop l'histoire
des deux barres
il a répété
où on joue assez vite sur la colonne E
la petite pétrole ça lui a bien plu
en tout cas en tout cas vous avez vous
avez quand même vu l'installation sur
vous le voyez pas encore enfin tel vous
le voyez sur la caméra mais c'est levé
exact exact on le voit bah ouais parti
aux toilettes peut-être
[Musique]
on sait pas trop ce qu'il fait mais il a
plu l'air très content de son install
bah non il avait fait un truc en plus
optimal
qui est bien c'est que
il voit pas ça du coup il se dit qu'il
lui pose des problèmes conso et un petit
peu long
enfin c'est juste
il joue à handicap très très beau joueur
sauf je te reconnais bien là avec ton
poulain qui joue à handicap c'est bon
voilà j'ai mis des caméras
je suis désolé c'est zoom qui a qui a
planté tout seul
c'est bon mais comme ça grâce à cela
vous avez pu voir ce dont on vous parle
depuis le début
honnêtement je vais 4 heures comme ça
c'est c'est dur dur allez un petit H5 là
on voit qu'il est pas du tout satisfait
ouais je vais pareil allez on y va on
pose les problèmes
il est pas il est pas à l'aise il est
encore deux barres il a deux barres
internet franchement je suis quitté
peut se permettre mais quand même c'est
risqué je joue très très bien ce qui
m'inquiète un peu c'est que je trouve
les cours
il y a pas un petit est-ce qu'on peut
que on peut pas faire
tu es en train de regarder kd7 très
intéressant je crois
parce qu'en fait si tu veux
[Musique]
d'ailleurs
excuse-moi je avec tout ce qui s'est
passé
il y a eu un petit ouais
caméra c'est encore cassé parce que j'ai
deux trucs insupportables
de faire ça et finalement il en rajoute
à chaque fois merci stuff à toi
mais là il y a eu un problème de et sur
Dame des quatre il y avait dame prend
des cartes cavaliers prend des cartes et
cavaliers F6 fourchette magnifique donc
là il a réussi à piquer le foot 15
novembre et maintenant la case noire
sont très affaiblies malheureusement
pour Abdou sa torov même si la connexion
de Wesley Sow est quand même assez
moyenne bah il se remet mal au temps et
c'est dommage parce que
ça peut se jouer là dessus on le sait
bien
c'est trop lent ce qu'il fait je sais
pas ce qui va nous faire en Bullet tout
à l'heure mais j'ai un petit peu inquiet
c'est prise de temps c'est pas NiAl
comme hier qui jouait tous ses coups à
fond en tout cas ils veulent une petite
finale pratique où il jouerait avec le
foot 15 noire
très actif
mais bon le cavalier en F5 paraît
intéressant
est-ce qu'on peut tenter un coup comme
G4 cavalier H4 peut-être dame G3 mais
qui RH4 je sais pas c'est bizarre mais
en même temps
est-ce qu'on peut jouer à H4 c'est dur
de d'évaluer pour faire hyper gaffe
parce qu'il y a des dames 3 par exemple
à l'histoire de d'un moment faire fouger
5 attention de ne pas se prendre dame
ranger 5 dames frangin 5 cavaliers 3
donc il est pas il est pas osé venir en
H4 non G7 c'est très intéressant et ça
va être dur de passer
dure de passer on a un petit peu moins
bien au temps on cherche
on a un beau fou c'est clair attention
il y a peut-être dame G5 ici qui est
intéressant aussi
cavalier aussi ça tient tout de la
boutique ça marche
si ça va mieux
donc peut-être dommage 4 fois F6 donc
dame G5 a été préféré est-ce qu'on peut
faire fouet 6 ici
c'est ça est-ce qu'on peut refaire
est-ce que tu reviens je pense
il faut prendre
c'est vrai mais oui c'est sûr que ce
coup-là qui m'inquiétait un petit peu ah
oui voilà d'accord bon bah voilà ça va
se changer je pense que ça va faire nul
on a un tout petit tout petit
plus parce que c'est pas facile de
bouger bon prise et RF6
c'est une position totalement bloquée
donc ils vont faire Roy fk3 G4 peut-être
on peut jouer F5 si on veut
surprise il y avait pas F4 et après le
roi vous pouvez ramener ici intéressant
ce qu'ils font en fait le renard
il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
passage F6 je peux attendre maintenant
roi des 6 rois 6 regarder et une
forteresse mutuelle
bon bah il a pas réussi avec les Blancs
à poser à cette problème et je trouve
que
wesleaux dans les ouvertures posent plus
de problèmes que Abdou Sa Torah
vous voyez là il a joué avec
pas vraiment la version qu'on connaît un
club
ouais mais c'est ça change quoi enfin ça
bouge des fois il a une bonne connexion
des fois non mais il a quand même filé
il a quand même filé une partie à cause
de ça on peut le dire
[Musique]
en plus
c'est une partie qu'il pouvait enfin qui
peut plus perdre et qui pouvait presser
pour gagner et il a perdu à cause de la
connexion donc ça me fait mal parce que
du coup bah là il y a deux deux dans
cette life il y a quatre points d'écart
donc voilà là
très sévère mais en tout cas elle joue
mieux et j'ai peut-être ouais j'ai gardé
la veste pour faire parler un petit peu
dans le chat et ça marche j'ai fait j'ai
failli changer de veste en vrai j'ai
failli changer de base mais je l'ai
gardé je me suis dit je suis sûr que ça
va faire réagir dans le chat et tu vois
ça manque pas j'ai toc ça vous fait
parler un petit peu
alors que d'où ça toi répète cette
position est quand même bon il a gay il
a gagné mais on sait comment quoi donc
prendre les cases de cavaliers
moi tu penses que cette chaise comme vu
l'installation franchement
[Musique]
soit il cherche comment il est installé
il est sur une chaise
pas au top
je sais pas
tu as pas une table qui traîne quelque
part tu poses l'ordi sur la table et tu
prends ta chaise d'ordi et tu t'asses
dessus tu sais non il est assis sur une
chaise en bois et il a l'ordi posé sur
le sur le sur le fauteuil de bureau quoi
c'est juste hallucinant quoi c'est pas
top top bah surtout quand tu perds une
partie à cause de ça c'est quand même
chaud leur match
soit montrer qu'il était au-dessus
jusqu'à présent mais on sait bien que
dès que la cadence change ça peut
s'inverser en tout cas Abdou sa torov on
voit on voit du pâté avec G5 dans cette
position ça contrôle la case F4 aussi
mais il veut balancer du du coup bien
gras et ce qu'il avait prévu F3 qui est
pas nécessairement le coup naturel
basique mais maintenant il y a une
pression sur le pion des 5
supplémentaire attention il y avait le
il va manger à 7 et attention qu'il y a
un problème sur B2 maintenant il a
fourchette en E3 qui peut arriver si le
fou venait à être bloqué éventuellement
un petit trap
et ceux qui est là
cette fait avoir
lieu trois en prime perdu
au score total donc la tête B3 il risque
cavalier quand même
pièce de plus nette il y a deux pions
pour la pièce mais les pions ne sont pas
assez
relancé cap d'où est très endurant
j'espère Alex que tu vois juste en tout
cas il est il est il est très sérieux et
et
il va pas se laisser abattre
tu vois normalement souffle le score
avant cette partie si s'il y a pas de
l'histoire de la connexion c'est 7,5
et du coup ça foute enfin une partie que
tu peux comme ça sur un élément
extérieur ça peut tout [ __ ] en l'air
donc il y a 3 G7 me semble-t-il et sur
kf5 je reviens en H8
ou en F8 et comme ça il y a plus ce
motif
[Musique]
pour avoir
facile de choisir entre ces deux cases
mais il est obligé de continuer
on est planqué mais il y a des motifs en
F7 F8 on est un peu plus ouvert mais en
même temps ça paraît assez stable ici
oui tu peux penser un truc comme ça et
genre peut-être faire du cavalier H6
pour faire pas mal
de savoir si tu veux venir en fuite ou
en H8 à des problèmes
[Musique]
hello hello
j'aurais joué avec l'agence
mais bon
les échanges
d'avoir une découverte ah mais il y aura
d'un pont cavalier en plus
de bien se passer autant c'est
l'entreprise
le dame de a surveiller allez peut-être
dameuse
très bien
on y va on a foi H4 aller abdos
de déconnexion
qui va être lancée maintenant
juste avant la pub et ben on a un ordi
Berck butorov qui égalise au score et
qui prend la tête dans ce deuxième set
donc c'est ça
j'espère que ça va nécessaire pour sa
connexion parce que là ça va pas du tout
très bien très très bien ouais quelques
petites bidouilles pendant la pause mais
qui dégrade un peu et c'est bon on va
l'emporter de manière brillante
il y a une particularité qu'il avait pas
dû perdre il a perdu autant à cause de
lui vraiment en plus elle était
magnifique cette partie c'était une
Master Class
la partie il aurait enfin je pense que
c'est pour gagner il avait 0 chance de
perdre les
ils avaient tous les deux peut-être cinq
secondes oui c'est ça mais il a commencé
allez la j'y crois là bon du coup on va
vous dire à tout de suite ne partez pas
restez parmi nous on se revoit dans
trois minutes pour le dénouement de ce
deuxième set en trois plus une donc à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour la partie qui a
commencé à l'instant
côté Wesley sceaux 6 et demi si c'est
demi dans ce match donc il faut bien
qu'il remonte au score
après ces problèmes d'internet donc ceux
qui a
qui a Jean-Luc camera enfin il y a un
truc bizarre comment la pose il a changé
des trucs
et
par stable voilà je sais pas si il a
fait un truc par rapport à internet
donc en tout cas on verra bien
alors
un petit peu un petit pressing après il
faut que j'ai quatre F3 tu penses que le
foot va être en H5 ou pas
en fait F3 on pose un petit problème
peut-être après avec Fouday 7 au
cavaliers
H5 était intéressant
c'était pas c'était vraiment dangereux
de jouer
clairement c'est stable quoi
standard de donner le fou ici
récupérer le dessin plus tard
peut-être un petit
et le fou souvent
j'ai failli rapidement proposer un petit
H3 mais bon il y a peut-être le retour
du
H5 et après j'ai 5 G4 toujours donc
autant
ok si je fais H3 il peut y avoir en fait
une création ici d'une rupture à base de
G5 H5 G4 sur le long terme avec l'Europe
a pas trop jouer des coups comme ça qui
ont l'air juste
juste trop facile bon il va falloir que
je passe par décapage un jour j'ai
cavaliers F5 comme motif aussi
moi je suis pourso dans ce match on a
parié avec Kevin du coup il faut que il
faut que tu arrêtes de bugger
donc à 4 à 5
full B2 ok c'est simple l'histoire du
point de personne avancé dans les
attaques si on touche au pion devant
notre droit ça peut accélérer
l'attaque adverse donc faut vraiment
éviter tant qu'il y a un roi non défini
là au milieu de l'échiquier
j'aurais pas du tout fait H3 j'avais de
la vie mais comme le roi il est encore
en outre c'est pas encore ce qu'il va
faire ainsi il fait H3 bah on va venir
faire grand rock plus c'est 5 en fait
donc l'idée en fait de pas encore donner
l'adresse notre roi ça
c'est intéressant donc là c'est les
Noirs qu'on a perdu fou mais la
structure est assez fixée la position
n'est pas ouverte donc c'est pas trop
grave
c'est plutôt chaud bienvenue à toi
hello à tous j'espère que tu vas bien
franchement on a du bol Stéphane à
chaque fois
les matchs à commenter enfin qu'on a
commenté tous les deux sont vraiment
ultra serrés à chaque fois ça s'est
terminé un petit peu au départage ou
quasiment d'ailleurs
et j'avais un peu de peine parce que
c'est dur enfin c'est plus dur à
commenter quand même
il a pas de chance ami en fait Wesley
profite que le roi au centre ne peut pas
se faire attaquer pour attendre kabdu
commis sur un sac
en fait Abdou lui ce qui fait c'est
qu'il va petit à petit commencer à
ouvrir le centre parce que le noir est
au centre et là on sait pas trop encore
vous voyez le roi noir donc en robe ça
m'a l'air quand même
je pense que il peut faire petit rock
encore je pense quand même le coup
normal petit rock mais grand rock c'est
c'est chaud il fait recomposer alors en
fait c'est chaud parce que même grand
rock c'est quand même solide et les
pères sont un peu difficile à faire tu
vois avec ces trois c'est pas facile et
il veut jouer ben j'imagine un petit G5
H5 rapide
[Musique]
pouce en l'air ok donc je fais prise et
cavaliers E5 peut-être voilà
on n'a pas envie de donner
génial fou des 6 peut être un coup
miracle qui va venir défendre ici c'est
le coup que je regarde sauf et je me
lance ce qui se passe après B5 donc tout
F5 c'est beaucoup plus safe on met notre
tour
mais si je contrôle les cases ça peut le
faire on gagne la pièce en E5 ça a gagné
direct c'est pour ça que j'avais peur
mais maintenant maintenant c'est ok
maintenant c'est un pressing pressing
blanc mais il y a toujours l'histoire du
temps quoi ça dorito le roi qu'ici
tranquille et au final et ben le roi il
est plutôt bien la colonne H qui était
ouverte alors dames 5 plutôt 5 je dirais
pour laisser passer le fou [ __ ] ici
mais c'est 4
savoir ce que ça vaut
mais le risque c'est quand même le petit
pion H2
bizarre d'avoir
ce risque de le jouer que dame G2 au
coup d'avant c'était aussi ah il y avait
il faut prendre des deux et d'apprendre
les trois ok comment on fait la il faut
faire quelque chose pour le spion H2
c'est pas sympa parce que ce pion aussi
il est faible hein
pourquoi il veut jouer
peut-être mais il y aura fou des 6 5
faut prendre les 5 peut-être il faut
faire attention
ultra importante
c'est la partie
c'est la partie alors fout des 6 cmg4
tour H4
[Musique]
compliqué la pose tout reprendre tout
run maintenant
19 37 secondes bon
bonne chance de nul je dirais cette
position
[Musique]
avec peut-être si
aussi jouer attention roi des 8 la
relief 6
peut-être avec le cavalier
il a pas gagné la case descend qu'il
allait en D7 mais c'est un petit peu
bizarre parce que maintenant il a un
problème j'écarte sans doute ça va être
dur du virus quoi quand il y a pas de
cases vraiment pour virer le roi
cavalier F6 pour ramener peut-être
cavalier très très bien joué c'est pas
facile est-ce que tout F7 avec une
découverte peut-être
[Musique]
il a des problèmes quand même la pièce
qui a été laissée
quand même d'abord
qui avance parce que moi je mange quand
même pas mal de pions là
je mange des pions tourgé 6 tourbé deux
secondes il faut se dépêcher qui va
arriver aussi et puis on a qui va qui va
arriver très très vite ouais
5 aussi et là il faut compter il faut
compter tourner
5 à cause de roi des Suisses attention
de ne pas tomber
derrière le plan
3 6
on joue pour le gain pour B5 et est-ce
qu'il peut la tenir celle-là c'est pas
simple mais voilà je pense un peu de
mien ça peut tenir c'est simple
j'ai cru là c'était pas très mérité si
gagner je pense mais bon alors le
badminton d'hier ils ont fait match nul
contre le village d'en face et le couple
du coup
Kévin plus compagne a gagné son match
exactement mais la tendinite la
tendinite est toujours là il faut jouer
avec on serre les dents pour essayer de
battre le village voisin en Néandertal
et on y va
j'ai cru là c'est tout j'ai cru alors
attendez quoi 3 et demi reste un quart
d'heure ça m'aurait fait du bien ça
m'aurait fait du bien ce plus de
voir beaucoup mieux c'est pas les
fameuses finales ou
non en fait tourpions
c'est juste simple
et au moment où tu dis ça Néandertal
professionnel réapparaît et nous parle
de défense passive
il faut défendre le cavalier
donc en tout cas
il me fait peur quand il est 100 ans
Stéphane il est au bord de la rupture à
chaque fois
il est beau de la rupture mais mais
Wesley Sow qui est quand même des
problèmes de connexion et je suis pas
tout à fait sûr non plus je te rappelle
quand même une partie qui a été gagnée
grâce à la connexion
dans cette position
je prends je prends là il prend ici ah
oui d'accord fous Decathlon
ici et s'il fait ça j'ai pas d'aménage 4
tu as un petit 3 échec
mais voilà
c'est c'est beau jeu hein
[Musique]
du F3 qui va gagner
plus vite et en fait sauge ou toujours
aussi vite calcule toujours aussi bien
un ge contre D
il y a pas de quoi tu parles en vrai
c'est pas si clair quand même
sur G6 puis avoir des problèmes avec
better sur la case aussi
un petit peu ouais un peu gêné par la
maladie
faut trouver le contre jeu sur la
colonne E tu auras des quatre
tout le temps tu auras des quatre pour
une fois je comprends d'où ça te RAF qui
est dominé autant ça s'explique beaucoup
plus puisque sauf une grosse partie lui
fait mal à chaque cours il est obligé de
prendre du temps et là peut-être il va
doubler sur H1 tout simplement faire du
temps au centre pour bloquer tout le
monde qui est pas mal aussi
prise adversaire et il va travailler
peut-être sur la colonne E au final avec
eux
arriéré maintenant donc C4 surprise faut
prendre
ces trois dame de il y a roi H3 et le
roi essaye pour reprendre échec
et s'il prend fou prend il y a des
menace de matelas eau qui est très très
dur apparaît et s'il prend pas ben du
coup mon pion maintenant il est bien je
pense même d'ailleurs plus tard faire
des choses avec B4 C5 pour venir aller
manger puis on Descartes c'est vraiment
gros plus et bloqué là j'ai tout je
pense que c'est ces gains assez facile
d'ailleurs je pense
techniquement à ce niveau là Kevin
je suis dépité
il a donné la dame
il est pratique même si on y croit pas
trop il est il essaie de trouver quelque
chose avec des foutu donc du coup il
tente des choses et en pratique il a
quand même une tour un fou il y a un
pion passé donc ça peut toujours
[Musique]
faire des choses
ils s'endort pas après avoir pris le
matériel et la graisse directe
comment tu veux jouer en fait parce que
c'est pas simple
pour pour jouer pour j'aimerais bien
jouer Beckham bien sûr c'est ça
exactement comme toi en fait
par exemple
de se couper tout ça
on a pas de menace de maths puisqu'on a
le congé 5 toujours avec les blancs
des champions donc A5 maintenant va être
joué avec des bases de jouer assez
social éventuellement
ça peut même être de jeu P4 pour
contrôler la Casa de la tour
parce que la tour pourra pas venir ici
pour défendre le pion et j'ai plus qu'à
pousser mon petit pion jusqu'à la
première
G5 le roi qui va s'envoler et surtout
ici il y avait encore BK4
et là maintenant c'est plus qu'une
question de temps
c'est bien ton abandon
on peut jouer
[Musique]
qui va revenir la tourbe pas vraiment
partir
t'as pas le choix mais ça va être
l'abandon très très bientôt alors qu'il
reste 9 minutes
dans ce temps on va avoir une partie de
décisive et
ils ont le temps
des trois on monte le roi peut-être tu
as roi le pion est gagné
[Musique]
son compte et ça reprend la tête avec 8
points à sec
je trouve et dans ce set et ben on est à
galité de nouveau
Abdou qui bascule maintenant à deux
barres c'est un combat de connexion je
croise
ce match en tout cas ouais sur la partie
échec vraiment on voit un
Wesley sceaux dominateur depuis le début
détruire ça ben
franchement j'espère oui mais je suis
pas si sûr que toi c'est à dire que pour
l'instant souhait est extrêmement rapide
dans les parties après des fois les
joueurs ils changent complètement
de façon de jouer et on a vu des joueurs
réputés plutôt lents avec des piles
électriques dans ce speechasse
là je pense que c'est pas clair du tout
mais en tout cas
ça va aussi à la connexion parce que les
deux joueurs n'ont pas une collection
fantastique on a déjà vu tout à l'heure
un saut par une partie par la connexion
et donc
son installation est bancale
c'est quelque chose mais le une plus une
c'est un Bullet de particulier quand
même je tiens à dire c'est pas vraiment
du Bullet en avion encore hier Sarine se
faire complètement dominer par par Iris
ambulette
dans tous les matchs qu'on a vu
auparavant quasiment et dans les bullets
c'est on va dire le joueur qui qui est
[Musique]
comment dire
de joueurs qui est
[Musique]
prévu pour être le moins fort qui va
toujours remporter ces bullets pour
l'instant c'est un peu ça c'est un peu
ce que ça
[Musique]
fait très souvent c'est ça un même
carwana qui a qui qui a fait la
remontada contre erikazé en buède alors
qui est magazine c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs sur terre actuellement en Bullet
et carbona c'est un joueur qu'on qui est
très fort
mais en Bullet c'est un joueur qui bon
qui modeste à son niveau et en fait non
il est éclater et dorylo oui
serait théorique plus longtemps en tout
cas il est plus à l'aise je pense pas
que cette théorique véritablement que
venait la théorie c'est juste que il est
plus à l'aise dans ces systèmes en tout
cas effectivement il nage il nage bien
dans dans le grand bain alors que
son adversaire effectivement semble un
peu plus poussif là il y avait encore un
écart de 20 secondes pourtant les blancs
on a dit que c'est de la pression donc
je suis assez d'accord avec ta remarque
globalement sans jouer sur les mots je
pense que c'est pas vraiment de de la
théorie pure si tu veux pas des coups
par cœur mais une meilleure
compréhension ou un meilleur travail de
ces systèmes il comprend bien les
nuances et du coup c'est pas évident de
passer non puis il joue plein de coups
simples et pratique sans sans se prendre
trop la tête mais la pression autant et
c'est ce qui fait 5 balance comme ça
alors c'est assez compromettant
j'aimerais bien avoir un petit F4 arrivé
il y a beaucoup de joueurs au final qui
qui réfléchissent plus ils prennent plus
de temps et en fait lui non et je
l'écoute pas faire la tête
sans rentrer trop dans le dans le calcul
vous voyez donc il a toujours une avance
au temps et du coup il met la pression
et c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il faut
faire en fait à ce niveau là
normalement Abdou va gagner il m'a
écouté là c'est exactement ce que je
voulais faire du coup normalement c'est
bon
G5
la structure est atypique un chinoise
mais les pions bec contrôlent les pions
blancs donc c'est pas c'est pas dit
qu'elle soit mauvaise
structure bizarre atypique mais pas pas
mauvaise dire que c'est dynamique H3
comme ça pas de ma du couloir profilaxi
il n'y a pas de coût d'amélioration très
nette donc on prend son temps attention
petite menace de cavalier F5 échecs
c'est le casier noir sans lèvre
mais bon ça serait un peu grossier il
est bien parce que il bloque le pioncer
et en fait
on aimerait bien faire ou décatte là
dans cette position peut-être très
rigolo avec le même mode
et D4 pour tu vois faire un petit E5
souffle même si pour l'instant le fou
aussi c'est qu'il y a des sept cadenas
parce que j'ai pas vraiment comment tu
passes je veux faire cavalier 4 après
cavalier
c'est la partie bravo
normalement il gagne sur deux coups là
normalement
c'est terminé
très très joli coup de Wesley a enlevé
la batterie sur la colonne F qui qui
menaçait de s'activer alors là je suis
un peu plus étonné parce que on donne
alors le pion passé ok mais il pense
qu'il va pas le bloquer avec la dame ou
le cavalier donc mais bon le plus passer
protéger et là
si tu veux il y a pas la contrepartie
quoi adverse G3 il reste trois minutes
25 dans ce set je sais pas si
pas évident de passer quand même
pression on répète on répond par une par
une menace
on peut pas la structure ce serait
dégueu et il y aurait prise et cavaliers
5 OK
comment comment on fait ici kg
tu vois est-ce qu'on peut faire cavalier
prend pion prend et F5 de folie
quand même
je sais pas trop quoi y penser
prise ces trois peut-être
attention il faut prendre des seins
comment on va faire la surfo prend des 5
oh là là
prise prise il reste 2027 c'est pourquoi
je dis ça
qu'on l'a vu là là à chaque fois qu'on
est mal au temple on se balade il arrive
pas à tenir le choc
là c'est trop dur pour lui là
il va tout devoir ramener 1 + 1
qui a gagné un coup non
plus quand même je pense que ça devrait
je regarde ses barres de connexion 4
bars
si c'est terminé
je peux revenir et
F3
attention avec la jauge qui s'affole et
ouais
il y a apparemment ceux qui auraient qui
aurait pas été précis il reste 50
secondes
il y a plus de temps ça va faire nul et
une dernière partie va être rejoint ce
set je pense ça va ça va répéter
il continue
la prise de risque
je le prends je peux poser des problèmes
il reste 30 secondes dans ce match
30 secondes
ah mais si je prends j'ai 4 c'est quand
même dur
[Musique]
même si il y a quand même des chances de
nul
10 secondes Kevin
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette finale
dam dam il y a pas Échec j'ai un pion de
plus
le temps est terminé Kevin
avec 3 secondes dans la pendule c'est
extrêmement dur
il y a plein de trucs là attention ou
d'objet 4 oh non et voilà
mais pourquoi il a fondu
et fin de la portion de 3 + 1 avec ceux
qui s'envole avec plus de et qui gagne
encore une fois ce 7
[Musique]
bien pris le
j'aurais bien pris la nul moi à sa place
cette partie encore et saut tu vois en
fait souvent il est mal mais il tient il
tient et tiens et tiens et tiens et au
fait craquer l'adversaire quoi et ça
c'est c'est ouf il est tellement solide
mais là quand même dans la finale de
pion il a quand même bien déconné et là
il ose
jouer la finale bon après il a vu qu'il
allait avoir un pion passé mais il a pas
eu le temps de voir qu'il avait perdre
tout son Éloi
mais c'était quand même hyper risqué
après il a voulu c'est digne des grands
joueurs il a voulu il a voulu jouer il a
perdu on a vu Niall qui faisait pareil
mais il a pas la même sérénité dans les
dans les ultrasons quoi après bon c'est
pas c'est ça c'est pas grave après on va
voir mais il va changer peut-être d'état
d'esprit complètement en un plus simple
on va voir on va voir on va voir si il
se fait détruire ou si il arrive à tenir
le choc donc il y a une demi-heure de
une plus une qui arrive dans quelques
minutes
donc plus de pour l'instant pour ce on
va voir un peu si dans son installation
avachi sur son fauteuil et il arrive à
tenir le choc contre contre donc en tout
cas une petite pause de 3 minutes et on
revient dans un instant on revient tout
de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par contre tu veux moi je suis prêt nous
sommes revenus
et je pensais que les joueurs avaient
commencé à avoir du tout
ceux qui s'installent qui remet sa
petite sa petite
son petit plaid sur le genou et qui va
pas encore en 1 + 1 Stéphane
peut-être changer la cadence comme ça ça
se verra bien qu'on est le moneytime et
deux fois quatre et demi 3,5
mais je trouve que ça
respecte la physionomie de ce qu'on a vu
depuis le départ avec Wesley Sow qui est
bien au dessus
j'ai trouvé Abdou sa torov un petit peu
long ça a été aussi une des différences
ouest les sauts plus solides il a perdu
d'ailleurs une partie sur la connexion
internet quand même alors que bon il ne
pouvait plus perdre donc le score
devrait être un peu plus large sur la
dernière partie peut-être que ça te rend
aurait pu faire nul mais bon il était
mal pendant quasiment la totalité de la
game donc finalement ça pourrait être
même plus sévère je pense après on a
plus simple on nous a dit les joueurs
vont changer de style et c'est vraiment
un autre domaine ce 1+1 donc j'espère
que Abdou ça t'aura va jouer très vite
cliquez sur les bonnes cases mettre les
pièces au centre là où il faut et gagner
le plan de bataille donc là du coup on a
vu jusque là lors de nos matchs que
notamment le joueur qui se faisait mener
arriver toujours quasiment toujours à
revenir dans ses bullets donc pour
l'instant on est à plus de pourceaux on
va voir un peu s'il y a un totorov
arrive à
[Musique]
dominer saut ils sont marrants les
joueurs parce que très différents tu
vois qui est vraiment très speed tu vois
il est il marque bien il montre il est
démonstratifs il est pas content Esso
tranquille avachi Poker Face
les installations c'est juste c'est
juste la folie chez soi pour ceux qui
viennent d'arriver je vous le dis
comment il est installé il est assez sur
une chaise en bois on l'a vu tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs
et il joue il a posé l'ordinateur
portable sur la chaise de bureau et il
joue du coup avachi de chaise à chaise
voilà et donc c'est complètement
incroyable il l'a souri qui est posé sur
le l'ordinateur portable
donc là en Bullet je sais pas comment il
va faire et j'ai bête sur lui donc je
suis un petit peu triste et je suis un
peu inquiet pour le Bullet du coup
tout à l'heure sauf qui a perdu une
partie par déconnexion
donc on espère qu'en Bullet et ben ça se
passe bien j'y crois encore mais bon
dans les fins de parties globalement
quand il était chaud en time ça a été on
va dire il a pas de problème de
connexion par contre quand même il a
joué quelques coups avec une
demi-seconde c'était très très chaud par
moment
il aime bien jouer avec le feu Sow allez
c'est parti on y va partir
et ça envoie l'ouverte alors que jusque
là alors il va mettre ou le fou en B4
voilà il joue ça de temps en temps
c'est un peu moins bonne réputation ça
c'est la ligne moderne qui avait
mauvaise réputation qu'on a peur de fou
maintenant ça va normalement il y a rien
et F5 des choses comme ça
[Musique]
normalement F5 E5 c'est assez thématique
à terme pour rétablir l'équilibre contre
la paire de fou
qui a été joué du coup
comment tu vas le footer 5 peut-être
j'avoue que je sais plus sauf
jusque là on est comme assez coup de
théorie c'est pas mal
voilà donc là il essaie de brider le
foot case noir parce qu'il est faible
sur case noir c'est logique en fait
les deux côtés
très très vite malgré son installation
ah oui l'idée 4 ça semble intéressant
il faut manger un tas pas le choix ouf
ok non il mange pas ça me paraissait un
peu incroyable de comprendre
ici en plus la garde pas donc c'est un
coup dur quand même pour Wesley dans ce
dans ce premier Bullet puisque là il
accuse 10 secondes de retard autant une
position pas facile parce que la tour
émulée il y a le cavalier qui peut
circuler dans cette position fermée
ouais là c'est très très dur moi c'est 6
tours des 6
parce que tour des 6 tout de suite il y
avait X5 on perdait la partie
et là c'est dur à tenir
mais bon
j'ai trois il est prêt à donner le
contreja maintenant c'est c'est toujours
mieux pour les Noirs mais peut-être un
tout petit peu plus difficile qui a été
très bien joué d'accord
[Musique]
hello hello ouais non mauvaise partie de
pour commencer de dessus
je sais pas ce qui se passe allez il a
juste pris une mauvaise décision quand
même Sophie il a pas fait totalement
n'importe quoi c'était plutôt bien je
pense et il a laissé le pion passer pour
garder sa paire de fou un réflexe colère
on peut dire ça attention ils ont une
plus un donc c'est on ferait vraiment
pas mieux on ferait largement moins bien
et d'où ça te RAF qui a fait une bonne
première partie
bon ça ça ressemble à l'italienne qu'on
faisait quand on était petit sauf qu'on
a commencé par par une espagnole mais
sinon cette position la connaît presque
on a déjà joué qu'on est tout petit
voilà ils ont limité maintenant on peut
jouer peut-être pour h4a oui je pense
qu'il y avait je pour H4 connaissant le
style
OK
alors on nous avait dit dans dans le
chat que Abdou a été fort dans le dans
le Bullet en tout cas pour l'instant
effectivement il fait une bonne
impression surtout si l'on compare à ce
qu'il avait fait il était un peu lent
5 + 1
qui fait un peu
sa caméra qui a bougé je ne sais pas
pourquoi
caméra aujourd'hui
on va travailler maintenant sur le pion
c'est pas très agréable à position de
Wesley sceaux
qui met une tour en A4 pour son idée
c'était de jouer G4 j'aimerais bien
prendre et on joue tout sur le pion
c'est
un bien joué tourner un voilà on va
jouer sur ses pions arriérés attention
au roi quand même
une dame des cinq peut-être voilà c'est
jouer trop cool
c'est très intéressant tout c'est jouer
d'ailleurs mais tout reprend des cartes
avec l'idée E5 ah bon
j'aurais mangé aussi
ça mérité de prendre du temps
le blender
qui est colère et qui perd cette partie
il fait pas mes affaires
24 minutes de jeu deux points pour pour
revenir mais
sa caméra fait que de bugger il me
saoule
la partie et
mais attention point de pénalité pour la
demi caméra de Wesley show
et j'ai perdu une caméra vous allez voir
que que
tu retourner
et en fait il est pas très mais sur le
sur le zoom et ben ça va être caméra de
derrière lui qui a disparu du coup à
partir
au niveau au niveau échec ça tient la
route ce qui nous propose
[Musique]
6 là
c'est la fessée
de la fin c'est il y ait plus du tout en
douceur il était dégoûté de cette fait
enfermer la dame un peu comme un enfant
mais on rappelle que c'est du 1+1 donc
ça ça peut arriver très très vite
mais il y est plus du tout
pour l'instant
[Musique]
il a fini par manger en 6
à 4 tranquille
c'est la gestion du temps regarder 20
secondes 40 en plus d'être très bien il
relâche un peu davantage
réfléchir parce qu'il veut continuer
même si la grande avance partout
alors je pense que ça risque de changer
OK
parce que il vient de voler un demi
point et sans doute le fait de rester en
vie donc maintenant il faut cliquer fort
le match faire une pause parce qu'on
voit pas le checker on va pas la caméra
la team stoufso la joue un peu à l'intox
au niveau technique
allez HK on envoie et on fait mat dame
de ça de bien jouer peut-être dame j'ai
4 ans
tour 8 modèle
la case F5 peut-être pour le cavalier
mais dans ce cas là peut-être le retour
du cavalier en D6 donc c'est pas encore
pas encore quelque chose ce qu'on fait
ces 5 pour faire vraiment le jeu
restriction et bloquer toutes les pièces
j'aime bien ces 5 mastouf et après on
faisait cavalier F5
on revient il va bouger il y a quand
même des choses à faire
des cavaliers
10 secondes il a joué un presque un peu
vite c'est parce que j'ai toujours dit
pour faire B4 B5
il veut plus jouer ses 5 cavalier B4 qui
a validé trois moments peut-être dame 3
kb4 qui a été trois
que il a repris automatiquement c'est la
question
pour moi
[Musique]
raté par son super il s'est rattrapé là
douce à toi il faut qu'il joue comme ça
tout le temps
il se prend un truc généralement il
abandonne pas
bon une belle tactique assez jolie en
vrai
[Musique]
c'est tombé là voilà
on reprend ce match donc
cette rencontre avec ceux qui qui a
juste un point de plus que que notre
diabète
et il est pour l'instant assez à l'aise
quand même d'où ça t'auras plus qu'en 3
+ 1 et 5 + 1 il a montré plus de
maîtrise mais il a bien fait je trouve
que il joue plus vite
donc ce qui est juste dommageable c'est
l'histoire
l'histoire de l'enfer mandat mais bon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur reprocher en
plus hein même si c'est rageant des fois
en plus ça on sait ce que c'est c'est
dur
on peut garder garder les pièces là
alors du coup comment on fait avec les
Noirs vous prend des trois ah oui à
chaque thématiques un cash 4
faut prendre un site d'apprendre à 6
d'accord
on a piqué le foodcasse blanche le jeu
blanc est au centre joue très très vite
là ça me fait peur parce qu'il y a du E5
j'aime pas trop la position noire ça a
été joué très très vite j'aime pas du
tout les Noirs parce qu'il fait mais il
y a du il y a du dessin aussi cavalier
F5 va être joué sans doute
ça va trop vite
tu as quand même une grosse pression sur
G7 moi je le bouffe quand même parce que
j'ai pas envie de ce qu'il fait autant
mourir le ventre plein il y a des
cavaliers aussi maintenant un peu stable
pour essayer de défendre
on de voit arriver avec tes grosses
pieds pièces alors toi aussi pour
avoir
tout de suite allez faut trouver les
coups précis peut-être un dames C6 tour
des 6 c'est la même idée c'est défendre
la casachis pour y aller c'est pas
facile cette position
est-ce qu'on a un coût pour sauver
a priori oui parce que la courbe
tome C2 incroyable écoute défense
comment est-ce qu'on tient ici la
tendance
c'est quoi le coup ici là c'est
incroyable parce que là c'est hyper
chaud
il doit se le dire il doit se dire qu'il
est mieux et trouver un couteau
on a envie de mater mais on peut pas
je pense que ça va pas prendre de risque
il va faire mieux là
ou pas
allez on continue
c'est fini
repart avec deux points de plus dans ce
match et qui est égalise du coup
dans ce troisième set
DAC DAQ combien il reste 15 minutes
c'est encore jouable
mais bon en face c'est fort aussi hein
ils doivent jouer les couilles c'est pas
pareil que commenter commenter à chaque
fois c'est la prise de risque et je vais
vite en plus dans ces positions c'est
très compliqué
l'adversaire regardez il y en a qui sont
cavalier sur ces cas-là
ok
de foot et 4 j'aime bien aussi le roi
sont bizarres
hello à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
pendant très compliqué encore on aime
bien avoir des deux côtés du jeu sur le
roi et là Wesley et c'est détendent
justement le jeu sur le roi est-ce qu'on
joue tour B1 ici X5
rigolo c'est 5 et du coup attention au
vis-à-vis quand même ça peut arriver ce
genre de choses
fou j'essaie
on met la presse on met la presse
prise
à cause de fou prends moi maintenant ça
existe ça serait énorme
il préfère cavalier 8 alors comment on
ramène du monde à la fête j'aimerais
bien faire cavalier
ça me fait peur parce qu'on voit
quelqu'un
salut
maudit
pour F6 mais il y a le matin
pour me faire un petit H3 il parle le
match là-dessus
[Musique]
d'un projet 3
on pouvait mais bon même plus besoin
ça va être le 10-0 en plus c'est pas
vrai quoi le pire score
commence
le dernier 8e de finale
de
et 12 minutes
[Musique]
mais bon
ça se joue à rien
mais là maintenant le plus 3 il fait mal
et Abdou Sa Torah font le son on le sent
quand même limite et il y a Robin 5 qui
me dit ça sent le Fanny
dans le bureau pour faire Fanny sous le
bureau
5 dans ces quatre et là cette position
va être dur encore parce que sur dame
prend dames suivi de F4 il y a des seins
qui arrivaient
pas aussi garder les dames et jouer pour
F4 F5 F4 sur mon va être joué ici
ah mais j'y crois encore il faut de
toute façon il faut gagner maintenant il
y a plus le choix
trois points de retard
il faut là il faut gagner voilà dès que
des cartes d'où ça t'auras faire une
partie le match est perdu maintenant si
personne là c'est terminé je pense voilà
chaque défaite chaque défaite ça sera
donc si l'on perd une seule sur les
parties à venir même en match nul le
condamne presque
donc maintenant
faudrait mettre un 3-0
mais allez faut le jouer petite pression
quand même noir c'est vrai
regarde pas
parce que le cavaliers
je pense
ouais mais il y a toujours la petite
pièce à Tanger 3 donc bon ça va
[Musique]
quand même
toujours les menaces est-ce qu'on peut
contrer pas vraiment
cavalier 8 finalement il a dû voir un
gars
s
il y a des cinq en l'air tu as un échec
là et là aussi attention
j'aurais bien aimé le voir le cavalier 8
revenir en jeu
5 au thème avec kg 4 qui pouvait arriver
la chose qui s'affole dans tous les sens
c'est pas facile pour les deux joueurs
ça va très vite à très vite c'est pas
simple moi ce que je vois c'est le temps
et le temps
c'est pas beau
d'un mec 6 est-ce qu'on balance notre
petit pion
allez là qui peut faire peur
c'est terminé
terrible
regrettable et maintenant rejoue sa
petite
[Musique]
on peut plus rien faire
ah c'est terrible stouf
j'aurais dû j'aurais dû comment
dirais-je partir partir pour faire
perdre westlesso et revenir
et revenir c'était
ma seule victoire c'est quand j'étais
pas là en fait je trouve finalement
c'est ça
avec le pion enfin le fou et ça en l'air
attention
en contrepartie
on prend tout reprend et cavaliers
il pense que le fou a pas forcément de
bonne case de
retraites c'est compliqué une bonne là
Abdou Sa Torah il s'est réveillé en 56
secondes
très qualitative
malheureusement
il lui a bouffé 30 secondes sur un une
minute
[Musique]
il a préféré tourger
45 secondes dans la partie
il a décidé de lâcher les chevaux
et je vais peut-être trop vite parce que
c'est en fait une position assez casse
gueule et maintenant il va peut-être
perdre
je pense qu'il a il s'est trompé avec
l'histoire d'échanger
tout ça pour ça
attention
et là c'est Wesley show qui s'est trompé
qui veut
qui veut comment dirais-je pimenter un
petit peu notre fin de
son il va se laisser tomber t'inquiète
pas il va il va perdre le maximum de
temps dans ce match
sur
et donc t'inquiète pas
de match c'est façon de parler parce que
non mais si jamais il est perdant en
fait juste pour dire si jamais il est
perdants il va il va pas se prendre la
tête il va il va prendre tout le temps
possible pour retarder l'échéance et
gagner du temps à la pendule sur le
temps réglementaire tu sais voilà
pour gagner un peu de temps la pendule
tu vois chaque coup il gagne une seconde
il va se tomber je pense qu'il va se
laisser tomber ah non
j'aurais pu mais bon oui non
il reste 4 minutes 30 pour 3 gains
d'affilée deux heures c'est impossible
mathématiquement c'est terminé par
contre j'espère toujours pas finir Fanny
et remporter
un seul en égalisant on a plus simple tu
vois où on en est rendu tout
on lance la machine avec un
il est four mais moins que son
compatriotes
[Musique]
ont fait aussi il y a des grilles de
qu'il avait fait aussi moi j'aime pas du
tout ça fait vraiment je trouve pas ce
sportif du tout j'aime absolument pas ça
la config du jeu qui amène ça ouais mais
bon bah c'est comme ça mais après c'est
les règles du jeu quoi mais je trouve
que c'est pas sport
c'est pas c'est pas beau geste ni beau
jeu mais après bah écoute c'est
un prank la tour est en l'air il
applique
il a fait du cavalier B6 cavalier dessin
cavalier B4 Cadd 3 cavaliers E5 voilà la
dernière manœuvre c'est énorme 5 coups
de cavaliers pour piquer un fou voilà
échanger le cavalier contre le fou
donc on voit qu'il fait quand même
traîner un petit peu les choses westlé
maintenant qui sait qu'il a gagné on
réfléchissant
un petit peu peut-être
trois minutes de jeu un appartement 3
minutes de jeu
il est en tout cas il fait un peu
n'importe quoi et je vais pas comme ça
du tout à l'heure là il a fini de
qualité
une pièce d'ailleurs
il continue
apocalyptique là
il me laisse revenir alors que bon
si vous pouvez m'aider un petit peu
voilà très très bien
voilà et là
il oublie à chaque fois il attend pas
les 15 secondes non mais il est traîné
mais après il va falloir abandonner tu
vois
maintenant il va essayer d'envoyer à
d'où ça torov mais c'est risqué je pense
tu vois il va essayer d'aller très vite
et qu'il puisse relancer une autre et la
gagner en fait ce qui va qui ça déconne
il va quand même prendre son temps voilà
et on lui demande de faire une partie il
va tomber pour pour gagner au temps là
regarde la ce oh là là là c'est pas vrai
mais c'est pas vrai faire ça oh là là là
là là là là là
alors que moi j'y croyais tu vois je
voulais au moins au moins en 1 + 1
gagner le minimax tu vois
qu'elle tristesse cette partie ça va
être la dernière
sixo la paire j'ai pas envie de
l'entendre des choses que tu vas dedans
[Musique]
c'est terrible d'entendre ça et c'est la
vérité
pour Kevin je parle bien
c'est pas vrai le dame F3
il reste 15 secondes
oh là là ça va être pas très belle
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a donné le
cavalier en G5
il est possible en plus qui se laisse
qui se laisse distancer c'est terminé le
match est terminé du coup
saute
et ça va faire ça va faire
[Musique]
au cas où
il est un petit peu comme moi
Néandertal il doit peut-être pas savoir
où est le bouton d'abandon ah s'il a
trouvé
[Musique]
bon du coup alors les gars pour pour la
suite
le match de Nakamura contre parabian
commence dans exactement 20 minutes donc
nous avec Kevin on va devoir rendre
l'antenne pendant quelques minutes afin
de régler tous les les réglage pour
deuxième match par exemple
tiens on a
so qui a changé de tête qui a vieilli un
petit peu à ceux qui a pris qui a pris
20 ans ou 30 ans
du coup voilà je vous disais on va faire
une petite pause pour faire les réglages
pour changer les titres pour faire tout
ça donc on se revoit dans 20 minutes du
coup pour le nouveau match et là le
match Nakamura contre par Aviane un
match donc
qui est 4 fois champion en titre de
du speedchaci contre paragraphiens
qui est qui est un grand maître quand
même 2600 hello qui s'est qualifié grâce
à un Tuesday qui va qui va forcément
rentrer contre du coup Nakamura je pense
match assez excitant et Nakamura qui est
ultra impressionnant qui a montré un
petit peu de quoi il est de quoi il est
capable
ultra favoris je crois que la bookmaker
donnait 99% pour la cas
donc voilà donc restez parmi nous dans
20 minutes les gars on repasse en ligne
pour la suite du match donc à tout de
suite